Okay, diesmal geht das Mikro nicht.
Das würde gebetet werden.
Ich habe gerade übelst fett Eis.
Richtig messig fettes Eis
gefressen.
7 Euro kostet ein Eisbecher mittlerweile.
Früher kam es aber 5 Euro schon teuer vor.
Also früher, vor 3 Jahren.
3, 4 Jahre.
Richtig, richtig.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, wenn wir gerade schon
bei Stellenanzeigen sind.
Okay, ich gebe zu scheiß Überleitung, weil
das hat mit dem anderen jetzt auch nicht viel zu tun.
Naja, wobei, doch hat es
in gewisser Weise.
Da wird es ja auch um unsere Gunst geworben.
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt
ein Wahl-O-Mat zur Europawahl
2024. Den können wir auch
später machen. Ich hoffe, diesmal sind die
Fragen nicht so hyperpepega wie
in den letzten Wahlen.
Oder vielleicht machen wir das auch zuerst. Keine Ahnung.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Der Markt regelt das.
Kommt da wieder raus.
60? Na, eher 50.
50.
Also, als ich
zum ersten Mal den Carsten
und den Fabian, also den Fraser
im Osten besucht habe,
von einer Weile her,
da kostete dort die Kugel Eis
noch 50 Cent.
Im Osten. Bei uns kostete es auch schon
1 Euro. Nein, ich will
definitiv nicht vor einmal
17,5 Euro.
Und ich vor allem
war 18. Das ist alles verbuggt as fuck.
Ich weiß nicht, was VmWare da treibt.
Okay, was
Prodcom da treibt?
Ich habe gehört, bei uns auf der Arbeit gibt es Stress
wegen Prodcom und VmWare.
Die haben tatsächlich auch schon Proxmox
evaluiert, aber das war nicht Enterprise Business
genug für uns.
Wir wollen auf Proxmox umsteigen.
Warum?
Proxmox zu günstig?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was kostet.
Ich glaube, dass Proxmox in der Standardvariante
gar nichts kostet.
Weil es gibt ja auch ganz viele
Homelab-Leute,
die da draufstehen.
Man kann sich wahrscheinlich irgendeine
Business-Support-Geschichte kaufen.
Ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt mit den
Business-Enterprise-Finanzierungssachen
von Proxmox, können wir gerade mal kurz gucken,
ehrlich gesagt nie beschäftigt.
Hyper-V,
also ich meine, wenn du Windows-Kisten hast,
Windows-Kisten laufen lassen willst,
lasse ich mir Hyper-V noch gefallen.
Ich meine, du musst dich da
eh zwangsläufig mit dem abgrundtiefen Scheiß
von Microsoft, was Server angeht, auseinandersetzen.
Gegen Desktop-Windows.
Ich benutze gegen Desktop-Windows,
sage ich ja gar nichts, hat auch viel Shit.
Aber Server-Windows ist einfach,
also wer wirklich ernsthaft Server-Windows benutzt
und das feiert, der hat,
weiß ich nicht, bei dem ist irgendwie,
kann immer alle Tassen im Schrank haben.
Das meine ich mit voller Überzeugung.
Immer wenn ich irgendwas mit Windows-Server sehe,
greife ich mir an den Kopf,
wie unglaublich dem ist.
Wie unglaublich dem ist.
Wie unglaublich das alles gemacht ist.
Sicherlich auch nicht alles schön unter Linux.
Oder unter BSD.
Aber was Windows da treibt,
allein schon wenn ich diesen komischen
Windows-Server-Setup,
wie heißt das?
Setup-Center.
Ne, wie heißt das Ding?
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Aufgaben-Planungs-Assistenz-Center.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Wenn ich das schon sehe.
Ja, mal gucken mal.
Jetzt kaufen.
Okay, jetzt kaufen.
Bei Subscription.
Okay, was kostet, wenn ich Proxmox...
Vor allem, die Frage ist,
was kostet Proxmox?
Mit der Enterprise-Lizenz?
Und was kriege ich dafür?
Ja, Server-Manager meine ich.
Ja, genau.
Dieses hässliche Ding.
Ey, das ist so ein...
Ey, guckt euch das an, Mann.
Ey, wenn ich das schon sehe.
Guckt es euch an, Mann.
Alter, was ein Schrott, ey.
Hyper-V auf den Notebooks.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass das da gescheit drauf läuft.
Okay, guckt mal.
Es gibt Community.
Moment, für Community.
Standard.
Premium.
Ah, Support-Tickets.
Response-Time.
Okay.
Business.
Business-Enterprise.
Kostet.
Proxmox.
VE.
Premium.
Subscription.
Eine CPU.
Ja.
Wow.
Ja, gut.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Unlimited Support-Tickets.
Response-Time, Tour, Hours, Business-Business und Critical...
Also, die Leute, das muss ja irgendwie bezahlt werden, ja.
Wenn ich mir das angucke, wie viele, was weiß ich, 32 Kern-CPU-Kisten bei uns da so eine Virtualisierungsumgebung ausmacht.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wir haben bestimmt, keine Ahnung, boah, ich weiß nicht, 1024 CPUs oder so.
Das heißt, dann würden wir pro Jahr eine Million, eine Million, äh, Proxmox, äh, naja, gut, das ist im Vergleich zu dem Campbell, was, was wir für Oracle ausgeben und so ja immer noch absolut lächerlich, ne.
Und was wir, und was wir für Forever ausgeben, weiß ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich ist das immer noch billiger.
Ah, ne, guck mal, es gibt auch vier, Moment, das ist, das ist einfach, das ist einfach das mal vier.
Ja, also zu billig kann es nicht sein.
Es ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Standard, was der Unterschied, okay, die Hälfte, die Standard ist die Hälfte, sind aber auch nur 10 Support-Tickets im Jahr und Dings.
Basic, guck mal, in Basic machen die gar keinen Remote-SSH, gar keinen Remote-Support.
Also, ich finde, Remote-Support ist tatsächlich Pflicht, wenn du dir so einen teuren Vertrag kaufst.
Ja, Chat, ich, ich hab letztens super geheime Sachen, was die SA Play ist.
Was die SAP Cloud angeht, gehört.
Ich hab zwar nix unterschrieben, dass ich das nicht sagen darf, aber ich sag's lieber nicht.
Aber ich sag nur so viel, die SAP Cloud ist nicht unbedingt das, was man auf den ersten Blick denken mag.
Keine Ahnung, wie secret das alles ist.
Wie gesagt, ich hab nix unterschrieben, ja.
Musste ja ein bisschen kecken, als ich's gehört hab.
Ich hab heute schon.
Sieben Kilometer.
Normal.
Durch den Wald gelaufen.
Und vorher eben gerade noch 35 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren.
Eineinhalb Stunden.
Das war keine allzu große Runde.
Aber relativ zügig.
Und.
Aber nicht so, dass ich jetzt übelst im Arsch bin.
Deswegen.
Eigentlich, eigentlich ganz nice.
Ja.
Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, wir streamen jetzt mal eine Runde.
Also, das ist auf jeden Fall definitiv zu viel für mich.
Daheim, ja.
Wobei.
Ganz ehrlich.
Man könnte, wenn man's unbedingt möchte, könnte man's machen, aber ich seh den Sinn nicht davon.
Ich mein, ich geb auch im Jahr 180 Euro für mein JetBrains All Desktop Package aus.
Das ist Business Enterprise Shit.
Ganz ehrlich, das sieht aus unserer Sicht so aus.
Aber, also, ich lässe ja auch immer ganz gerne über SAP und Oracle und sonst was.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass alle, die Oracle und SAP anschaffen, nicht so gut sind, dann ist das nicht so.
Also, ich lässe ja auch immer ganz gerne über SAP und Oracle und sonst was. Aber ich glaube, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass alle, die Oracle und SAP anschaffen, nicht so gut sind, dann ist das nicht so gut.
Wenn einfach nur dumm sind, greift man zu kurz.
Dummheit ist immer so ein bisschen so das Letzte, was man eigentlich...
Ich mein, es ist oftmals der Fall, ja.
Aber, damit kannst du nix anfangen, wenn du Dummheit vermutest, ja.
Also, geh ich davon aus, die machen das absichtlich.
Und gerade im SAP-Umfeld ist es halt so, es gibt halt in vielen Sachen oftmals SAP.
Das integriert sich am besten mit SAP.
Und deswegen kaufen die Leute dann weiteres SAP.
Das ist genau so.
Wie der, wenn der bei größeren Versicherungen und Banken unterwegs bist,
die, die, diese ganzen Wirtschaftsprüferläden omnipräsent sind, ja.
Du hast PwC, EY und, und wie heißen die anderen Typen da?
Es gibt vier, vier große gibt's da.
Überall, überall kastern die rum.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die da eigentlich alle machen.
Okay, wir haben ein paar Leute tatsächlich von einem der großen vier, zumindest zwei.
Da muss ich sagen, die machen tatsächlich was für ihr Geld.
Wobei, wobei die nichts machen, wo ich mir denke,
das hat jetzt eigentlich nicht so direkt was mit Wirtschaftsprüfung zu tun.
KPI, die gibt's auch noch, genau.
Das kann sein, mit denen hat ja nichts zu tun.
Naja, egal.
Tschätke, bevor, bevor wir mit dem Stream richtig anfangen,
falls ihr irgendwelche Stellenanzeigen habt, die wir uns angucken sollten,
dann sagt Bescheid, vielleicht gibt's was, wo ihr euch bewerben wollt,
wo ihr arbeitet.
Und, ja, das hatten wir auch schon öfters, Leute, die ihre Stellenanzeigen geschickt haben,
so nach dem Motto, Max, wie findest du das, würdest du dich ja drauf bewerben.
Weil ich bin immerhin, hier im Stream, muss man ja auch mal sagen,
ich bin ja quasi so das, das Klientel, was man ansprechen möchte, mit seinen Stellenanzeigen.
Ansonsten gucken wir bei den üblichen Verdächtigen ein bisschen durch, was einen da so anspringt.
Leider habe ich gerade keinen LinkedIn-Fake-Account, auf LinkedIn gibt's auch immer lustige Sachen.
Auf LinkedIn eskalieren sie.
In letzter Zeit ein bisschen.
Mit ihren Posts, ähm, how to fire people und sowas.
Die ganzen CEO, oder sagen wir mal so, die ganzen fünf Mann, ja, einfach in Chat reineliminieren,
wie man früher gesagt hat.
Die ganzen Möchtegern-Fünf-Mann-Unternehmen-CEOs, die sich so übelst abfeiern,
auf LinkedIn und, man kann das gar nicht beschreiben.
Das ist teilweise so cringe.
Heute Morgen habe ich einen Post gelesen von einem, Dell wurde Data, ne,
ne, hab ich nicht, schick mal, gibt's da was von Heise oder so, schick mal, hab ich nicht mitbekommen, ja.
Heute Morgen habe ich einen Post gelesen von einem, einem CEO, und der hat, und der hat geschrieben,
also das war eine englische Stellenanzeige, er sucht quasi einen Assistent,
und, also wohlgemerkt, das war ein Unternehmen, was vor einem Jahr noch vier Mitarbeiter hatte,
und jetzt gewachsen ist auf zwei bis zehn.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie man sich das vorstellen soll.
Sind die jetzt gewachsen, oder?
Ja, geschrumpft.
Ich interpretiere immer noch das Schlechteste rein.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile ist er alleine mit seinem Assistent oder so.
Das ist, das ist so eine typische LinkedIn-Sache.
Unternehmensgröße, vier.
Nächstes Jahr, zwei bis zehn.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ist das jetzt 50% geschrumpft, 200%, 3% gewachsen?
Naja, hab ich, hab ich heute auch wieder so einen LinkedIn-Post gesehen,
von einem CEO, der sich, der sich super, super abgefeiert hat, gemeint, er sucht,
er sucht einen Assistent.
Und er hat gesagt, es ist eine Position, wo man viel lernen kann.
Und bitte fragt erst gar nicht nach dem Gehalt, das macht sich nicht gut.
Und das ist eine, das war auf Englisch geschrieben, das ist eine super Learning Opportunity,
einem CEO on fire aus der first row über die Schulter zu schauen.
Das hat der Typ wirklich über sich geschrieben.
Das ist so lost, was da aussieht.
Auf LinkedIn geschrieben wird.
Mann, das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Möchtet, möchtet ihr nicht auch umsonst arbeiten als Assistent?
Für, aus der front row, für einen CEO von einem zwei bis zehn Mann Unternehmen,
was richtig on, der richtig on fire ist.
Boah, ich hab übelst Lust, Leute.
Nehme ich jetzt hier ohne Gefahr meinen Traumarbeitgeber, ja.
Ja, so liest sich das fast.
Learning Opportunity.
Ja, ihr wisst doch, das ist genauso wie auf YouTube.
Twitch und sonst wo, Leute, die Emotes machen, Intros machen und Thumbnails machen und sowas,
total oft die Antwort bekommen, ja, wir bezahlen dich mit Exposure.
Dass er sich von Exposure allein nichts zu futtern kaufen kann, ist wieder das andere.
Exposure.
Also es ist ungefähr das gleiche.
So, ich mach mal kurz, was hab ich denn hier jetzt aufgemacht gerade?
Ja, das wollte ich mal.
Ich mach mal kurz Package Updates, weil 8, by the way,
selbstverständlich gibt's wieder 2.000 Updates.
Was ist, ah Moment, was ist Geo Clue?
Manchmal hab ich Zeug installiert, da weiß ich nicht, was es ist.
Geo Clue.
Modular Geo Information Service, built on the D-Bus-Message.
Das sind zwei Sachen, die passen in meinem Kopf nicht zusammen.
Warum brauch ich Geo Informations über D-Bus?
Whatever.
Egal.
Der hat ja nicht gesagt, dass er umsonst arbeiten soll, der hat nur gesagt, don't, man soll erst gar nicht asken für, äh, wie viel es gibt.
Er hat nur gesagt, don't, äh, man soll erst gar nicht asken für, äh, wie viel es gibt.
So, weil das so eine geniale Learning Opportunity ist.
Leute, ich bin, ich bin ein wenig, ich bin minimal stolz auf mich, ich hab meine, meine Social-Sachen letztens besser im Griff gehabt als sonst.
Und zwar, ihr wisst ja, ich bin oftmals über jeden Scheiß gerne getriggert.
Was mir besonders auf den Sack geht, wenn irgendwie einer mir erzählen will, wie ich was, wie ich was machen soll und so.
Obwohl das ein Thema ist, womit ich mich auskenne.
Oder mir erzählt,
das stimmt nicht, obwohl das aus meiner Sicht genau richtig umgesetzt, also, ihr kennt mich, ich bin ja immer ganz gerne ein bisschen getriggert von allem Möglichen.
Und letztens auf einem, auf einem unserer Dailies meinte jemand aus dem Team zu mir so, Max, du erzählst immer so wenig zum, im Daily.
Und ich so, ja gut, gibt auch nix wirklich Interessantes, ne.
Äh, gut, du hast mich jetzt exposed, dass ich nix mache, aber, äh, was soll ich groß erzählen?
Ich, ich mach ja absichtlich, ich erzähl ja absichtlich nicht so viel.
So, und er meinte, ja.
Und ich hab dazu irgendwie die Bedenken, ich würde was machen und, äh, das dann absichtlich nicht sagen, damit's keiner mitbekommt.
Da hab ich mir so erstmal, da war ich erstens, da war ich erstens ganz kurz davor, mich aufzuregen, weil ich mir gedacht hab, Leute, was haben die Leute immer für Fantasien, man?
Ich mach das absichtlich, damit wir unsere 15 Minuten einhalten.
Wir haben 15 Minuten Daily, in dem zu 95% komplett überflüssiges Zeug gelabert wird.
Da mach ich halt einfach nicht mit.
So.
Weil wir uns auf unserem letzten, äh, Team, frag mich nicht, Workshop, explizit drauf geeinigt haben, dass es vollkommen okay sein muss, damit wir das so in der Art und Weise machen können, wenn man sagt, ich hab nix und ich praktiziere das auch.
Ich sag wirklich in unserem Daily nur was, wenn's was Relevantes ist und was auch alle interessieren können.
Mich interessiert auch nicht, was die Leute für Tickets bearbeitet haben oder was für, äh, ja, keine Ahnung, irgendwie bei irgendwelchen Services, wovor ich keine Ahnung von hab, irgendwas gefixt wurde.
Also, wenn es nicht das Team betrifft, hat das auf der Teamrunde erstmal pauschal nix, nix zu suchen, ja?
So.
Und so mach ich das auch.
Zumindest, ich hab mich zusammengerissen und war nicht getriggert, weil ich, ich kenn denjenigen schon, der ist, der meint das nicht so, ja?
Genauso wie ich mich da ein bisschen dran, der meint das nicht so, der meint das eigentlich gar nicht böse.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, ähm, den rufst du jetzt einfach danach nochmal an.
Und dann haben wir da kurz drüber geredet.
Und da hat er gemeint, ja, war.
Das, das.
Das meinte er auch gar nicht so, wie es sich angehört hat und ihn würde einfach ein bisschen mehr interessieren, was im Cloud-Umfeld so abläuft.
Da habe ich gesagt, okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen, gerade weil man da nicht so viel damit zu tun hat.
Ja, wenn es da irgendwas gibt, ich überlege mir mal, vielleicht gibt es da irgendwas, was zumindest ein paar interessieren könnte.
Mal gucken, ich achte mal drauf, ob es da tatsächlich vielleicht irgendwas gibt.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, ich glaube, so ist das, wie das sozial normale Menschen handhaben.
Also nicht so, wie ich das normalerweise mache.
Ich glaube, so, wie ich das diesmal gemacht habe, ist das, wie das normale Leute machen.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, weil ich bin ja nicht so wirklich normal, was soziale Sachen angeht.
Ich habe letztens einen Artikel gelesen, da habe ich echt erstaunlich viel...
...von mir drüber wiedererkannt.
Das war ein Artikel, der hat geschrieben, äh, Artikel ist zu viel gesagt, das war ein Reddit-Post.
Und er meinte, er hat nach 20 Jahren oder so, irgendwie in dem Dreh, hat er gemerkt, dass er eigentlich nicht...
...sich, in Anführungszeichen, normal verhält, sondern sich abguckt, wie andere Leute sich normal verhalten, um das dann auch zu machen.
Ohne wirklich jetzt genau zu...
...verstehen, warum die Leute das in der Situation sich so und so verhalten.
Und da habe ich mir ein paar Mal, da habe ich mir ein bisschen, das fand ich echt gut geschrieben.
Ich muss kurz nebenbei gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Da habe ich mich echt wiedererkannt, weil gerade...
...aber weil gerade in so vielen, so Social-Situationen, wo ich damit überhaupt nichts anfangen kann...
...habe ich, mache ich das auch total oft.
Wie so, mir zu überlegen, okay, wie würde sich denn jemand...
...anderes jetzt in dieser Situation verhalten, beziehungsweise, was habe ich schon mal gesehen?
Vielleicht, ey, keine Ahnung, kann durchaus sein.
Also ganz ehrlich, man kann ja nicht sagen, 0% und 100%, so in dem Sinn.
Aber, also bei allen meinen Sachen bin ich auf jeden Fall eher auf der Autismus-Seite, als auf der auf gar keinen Fall-Seite.
Gerade was meine sozialen Sachen angeht, ey.
Aber ich kann mich wenigstens zum größten Teil zusammenreißen.
Und eine Sache, eine Sache hat bei mir echt enorm geholfen.
Und das ist, sich nicht mehr zu irgendeinem Scheiß zwingen, wozu man keinen Bock hat, sondern sich zu trauen, weil das ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes, zu sagen, wenn man keinen Bock hat, ja.
Gerade wenn ich auf irgendwelche Sachen mit, ey, wir gehen heute Abend noch was trinken oder so, wenn ich dann sage, ey, das ist mir zu spät, ich muss noch ein paar andere Sachen machen, ähm, viel Spaß.
Die nehmen das einem zu 99% gar nicht übel.
Früher habe ich mich tatsächlich nicht getraut.
Da bin ich dann manchmal mit bei solchen Sachen, obwohl ich eigentlich gar keinen Bock hatte.
Seitdem ich jetzt einfach sage, oh ne, oder auch Sommerfest und sowas, da sage ich immer, klar, ich ne, die wissen das schon mittlerweile.
Die sagen, ah gut, der Max kommt eh nicht.
Sag ich, ja, wohl, aber viel Spaß, Leute.
Die nehmen einem das nicht krumm.
Und wenn sie es einem krumm nehmen, dann ist das ihr Problem.
Nun ja.
Ja, Leute, falls ihr noch, falls ihr noch Stellenanzeigen habt, die wir uns angucken sollen.
Weil ich LinkedIn so mag, ja.
Ja, alles.
Daily Reports Customer Data Preach.
Aha.
Jahres Kickoff.
Ey, Jahres Kickoff ist bei uns gar nicht so schlecht.
Jahres Kickoff ist bei uns viel besser.
In der letzten Firma, wo ich war, da war Jahres Kickoff immer eine Vor-Ort-Veranstaltung.
Die haben sie früher öfters im English Theater abgehalten.
Das haben die sich gemietet.
Kennt das jemand in Frankfurt?
Da haben die sich das Ding gemietet und haben dann auf der Bühne ihre, ihre, ja, Motivationsreden geschwungen.
Und das war so cringe bei uns früher.
Wirklich.
Das war...
Wie soll...
Wie kann...
Ich muss euch das vormachen.
Anders kann...
Beschreiben reicht nicht.
Das war dann so.
Und wir haben wieder eine Umfrage zur Mitarbeiterzufriedenheit gemacht.
Und was kam raus?
Ein sehr gutes Ergebnis.
Und wir haben wieder einer weiteren Kundenumfrage erster Platz bei den besten Außendienstleuten gewonnen.
Und auch für dieses Jahr sind wir wieder die Besten der Besten.
Und für die Besten und die Allergeilsten.
Das ging ohne Scheiß.
Das war, das ist nicht übertrieben, das war alle 15 bis 30 Sekunden Applaus.
Unsere Jahreskickoffs früher.
Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass sie damals sogar so Anklatscher im Publikum sitzen hatten.
Also es gab, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten bei dem letzten Laden, wo ich war.
Entweder...
Also wie gesagt, nicht beim aktuellen, beim letzten.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten bei dem letzten Laden, wo ich gewesen bin.
Entweder waren das wirklich gepriefte, so Anklatscher, so nach dem Motto, hey, so Leute von, keine Ahnung, Sekretärin oder so oder Sekretär.
Oder das waren Leute, die in diesem System schon oder in diesem ganzen Ding so gefangen waren, dass sie es wirklich gefeiert haben.
Wo hat das nochmal gearbeitet? Das ist nicht public, das sage ich nicht.
Ich habe, ich habe bei einer größeren Bank in Frankfurt gearbeitet und jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Versicherung in Frankfurt.
Da gibt es so viele in Frankfurt, das kommt nicht, das kriegt ihr nicht raus.
Hast du eigentlich flexible Arbeitszeiten? Ja, habe ich.
Echt? Es gibt Unternehmen, die in der IT arbeiten oder arbeitest du in der IT? Weiß man ja nicht.
Und die das nicht haben? Wirklich?
Also ich hatte das schon immer.
Sogar bei meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb hatte ich das schon.
Ja, echt jetzt?
Also ich habe ja meine Ausbildung bei einem Internetprovider gemacht, der nicht in Frankfurt sitzt.
Also es ist nicht die Telekom, wie das manche schon öfters immer da vermuten.
Es ist nicht die Telekom.
Und sogar da hatten wir das.
Ja, ist auch. Nein, es ist auch nicht Wodafunk gewesen.
Eigentlich völlig unnötig.
Ja, ist es auch.
Also generell vor Ort zu sein ist unnötig.
Bei manchen Sachen macht es durchaus Sinn.
Ab und zu mal, aber bei vielen Sachen ist es...
Ja, leider. Naja, gut. Ja, das stimmt schon. Es bleibt aber nicht viel übrig.
Wenn man nicht... Oh, mal zurück zum Thema.
Dazu kommt des heutigen Streams.
Nein, ich bin seit 27 Minuten erst on.
Wenn du noch was hast, schick rein.
Vielleicht ist ja heute was für euch dabei.
Hat es denn dort eine flache Hierarchie bei uns, meinst du jetzt?
Ah!
Nee.
Würde ich nicht sagen.
Oh, das habe ich noch gar nicht.
Nee, das habe ich schon. Das habe ich schon.
Ich glaube, das habe ich schon alles aufgemacht.
Oh, come on.
Bange.
Mod-Check. Mod-Check.
Wisst ihr, Bots auf YouTube sind auch viel krasser.
Unter jedem scheiß Video auf YouTube hast du mittlerweile AI-generierte Chat-Nachrichten.
Oder halt Comment-Nachrichten.
Das ist so schlimm. Man erkennt es teilweise gar nicht mehr richtig.
Weil mittlerweile verschwimmt Dummheit und AI.
Also viele Comments, wo ich denke, dass die AI sind, sind wahrscheinlich gar nicht AI.
Die Leute sind einfach nur dumm.
Und umgedreht.
Auf Twitter auch.
Wisst ihr, was das Top-Bot-Comment auf Twitter mittlerweile ist?
Nach jedem Post.
Meine Nacktfotos im Profil.
Kennt ihr das auch?
Twitter-Post.
Ja.
Meine Nacktfotos im Profil.
Ist immer, immer auf Twitter, Mann.
Was im Post?
Teilweise kriege ich irgendwelche Antworten auf Tweets von vor drei Jahren.
Meine Nacktfotos.
Was im Profil.
Direkt Bann.
Alles gebannt.
Bange.
Klickst du das an?
Okay, das würde ich vielleicht von meinem Browser unter Linux machen.
So, Package-Updates.
Let's go.
Package-Updates, dann Reboot, dann gucken wir uns Stellenanzeigen an.
Also wenn ihr was habt, immer her damit.
Falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, könnt ihr es ruhig noch mal posten.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe alles, was bisher gepostet wurde.
Mitbekommen.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Was ist denn bei Dell los?
Dell Reports Customer Data Preach.
Ja, zum Glück habe ich bei Dell nichts, was gepreacht werden könnte.
Dell warned in an E-Mail to customers that there was access in the data breach.
Including names and addresses to companies located in...
Und was genau ist passiert?
Was passiert?
Und wie genau hat, wie genau, also was genau ist da jetzt passiert?
Das ist natürlich auch immer ganz interessant.
Also, okay.
Dell reagiert nicht auf Warnung vor Diebstahl von Kunden an.
Es ist überall der gleiche Scheiß, man.
Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit der Gamescom?
Bei der Gamescom war es auch so.
Da hat jemand die Gamescom, beziehungsweise nicht die Gamescom, die Köln-Messe muss man ja sagen,
darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass man Daten abgreifen kann über das...
Also, wenn man dort sich einen Account gemacht hat, konnte man Daten abgreifen von anderen Leuten.
Und das hat er irgendwie Post vom Anwalt bekommen.
Sowas muss, und das ist wichtig, sowas muss immer einen riesen Shitstorm geben,
dass die alle merken, dass es teurer ist, sich auf sowas einzulassen, wie einfach ihren Scheiß zu fixen.
Sowas regt mich immer schon auf, wenn ich es einfach nur sehe.
Ja gut, zum Glück, zum Glück habe ich bei Dell nichts registered und nichts gekauft.
Ja, ist aber kacke.
So, also, let's go.
Mit was fangen wir denn an? Was haben wir denn hier?
Was haben wir denn hier so?
MPG Trier, Systemadministrator, Cloud-Virtualisierung, ZEVDESK, Systemadministrator, MVX,
Moment, das hatten wir doch gerade schon, das hatten wir auch schon, das hatten wir auch schon.
Entry-Level IT, Architect Expert Lab, jetzt wird es aber abgedreht hier.
Ja.
Und 1.
Ich glaube, der hier wurde als erstes gepostet, deswegen machen wir den hier auch als erstes.
Ein Frontend-Developer für React aus Leidenschaft.
Stand...
Was zum Teufel ist ein Entry-Level Expert?
Oder ist das ein Expert Labs?
Egal, wir fangen mit dem an, was zuerst gepostet wird.
Also, Byte5.
Byte5 GmbH, wo sind die?
Frankfurt.
Okay.
Bei mir um die Ecke quasi.
Guck mal, davon abgesehen, ich würde nicht unbedingt React-Developer werden wollen, aber man weiß ja nie.
Ich bin da eigentlich ganz happy, wo ich aktuell bin.
Aber zeig mal her.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Die sind in der Nähe vom Ostbahnhof.
Das ist die Europäische Zentralbank hier, das Ding.
Was ist da unten der Knopf?
Ah, Cookie-Stelz.
Okay.
Also.
Äh, wer hat denn diese...
Wer hat denn diese Stellenanzeige gepostet?
Ich frage aus dem Grund.
Ist das...
...die Stellenanzeige von dem aktuellen Arbeitgeber von dir?
Willst du dich da bewerben oder nur was, was du zufällig gefunden hast?
Okay, zeig mal her.
Also.
Sie suchen einen Frontend-Developer für React aus Leidenschaft.
Wie immer, männlich-weiß-deutsch.
Byte5 GmbH sichert den Erfolg unternehmenskritischer Projekte für Mittel...
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Ich...
Ich nehme wohlwollend zur Kenntnis, dass man seine Selbstlobpreisung auf ein Minimum beschränkt hat.
Nicht wie manche andere Stellenanzeigen, wo die erste Seite Selbstlobpreisung das Ausschreibende ist.
Deine Aufgaben.
Als Frontend-Entwickler für Ja...
Äh, nicht Frontend-Entwickler, JavaScript.
Für React betreust du von Anfang an verantwortungsvolle Kundenprojekte mit JavaScript unter Verwendung gängiger Frontend-Frameworks wie React.
Ich frage mich immer, und das liegt jetzt nicht an dieser Stellenanzeige, ich frage mich immer, warum die Stellenanzeigen so geschrieben sind, wie Stellenanzeigen geschrieben sind.
Warum schreibt man nicht einfach, ja, mit JavaScript und React unter Verwendung gängiger Frontend-Frameworks wie React, ihr sucht doch explizit einen React-Developer.
Warum sind die Dinge immer so, so...
Wie könnte man das nennen?
So um die Ecke geschrieben.
Gemeinsam arbeiten wir mit dir an deiner Reputation als Spezialist.
Whatever auch das bedeuten soll.
Was kann ich mir da drunter vorstellen?
Gemeinsam arbeiten wir mit dir an deiner Reputation als Spezialistin.
Spezialist, Spezialistin.
Was soll mir das sagen? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Nun gut.
In deinen Entwicklungsprojekten bist du an allen Projektphasen beteiligt.
Von Start über Design, Implementierung und Test.
Bis zum Live-Gang, Abschluss.
Ja, gut.
Developer, Berater, Trainer.
Bei uns kannst du alles sein.
Ich möchte eigentlich Frontend-Entwickler sein.
Kannst du alles sein und dich je nach Vorlieben und Projekt immer wieder neu positionieren.
Bei jedem Schritt deiner Entwicklung kannst du auf das Wissen, die Kontakte, die aktive Unterstützung des Teams bauen.
Okay.
Also ich kenne enorm wenige Entwickler, gute und auch gute Entwickler, die gerne Berater bzw. Trainer sein wollen.
Aber kann ja sein, dass es den ein oder anderen gibt, der da Bock drauf hat.
Das bringst du mit.
Wir wollen die Besten noch besser machen.
Dafür brauchen wir zur Unterstützung ein Frontend-Dev-Junior-Intermediate-CD.
Was denn jetzt?
Alles.
Sie nehmen alles, oder?
Es ist, es ist ja, man könnte es einfach weglassen.
Okay.
Sie brauchen irgendeinen, der davon Ahnung hat.
Mit Programmiererfahrung und der richtigen Einheit.
Einstellung.
Echte Leidenschaft für das Entwickeln und Gestalten.
Mut und Bereitschaft zum Out-of-the-Box-Denken.
Das sind auch immer so krasse, das sind so heftig, so Phrasen, die da immer drin stehen.
Das mit Out-of-the-Box-Denken ist so ein Spruch, der steht gefühlt in jeder zweiten Stellenanzeige drin.
Spaß an richtig, richtig guten Weblösungen.
Hervorragende HTML, CSS, SCSS.
Ist das überhaupt noch ein Ding seit den letzten CSS-Updates?
Nicht so wirklich, oder?
TypeScript, JavaScript-Skills.
Bevorzugt die genannten Frameworks.
Ja, React.
Habt ihr bis jetzt gelernt.
So.
Erfahrung mit Prototyping.
Fick mal, XD.
XDing.
Ne, XD ist das Ding von Adobe, aber.
Liest sich jetzt irgendwie so.
Fick mal, XD.
Agile Grundlagen und selbstständige Arbeitsweise.
Sorry.
Agile Basics.
Und wer Leute und wer keine Agile Basics hat, muss demnächst zum Agile Wake-up-Call.
Habt ihr das gesehen, was ich letztens auf Twitter gepostet hab?
Moment.
Ja.
Die Mail hab ich auf der Arbeit bekommen.
Sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen, da muss ich mich noch wegmachen.
Ich möchte euch in diesem agilen Wake-up Beispiel und Best Practices für das agile Arbeiten vorstellen.
Dabei beginnt der Vortrag.
Der Vortrag mit einem kleinen Landing und geht dann auf zwei bis drei Beispiele.
Du brauchst eindeutig einen agilen Wake-up, dass du das machen kannst hier.
Fähigkeiten auf Deutsch und Englisch zu kommunizieren.
So arbeiten wir.
Ich muss sagen, das letzte dreiviertel Jahr über hat sich mein Englisch enorm verbessert.
Also, dass ich kann reden auf Englisch enorm verbessert.
Einmal, weil man auf der Arbeit öfters mal mit Leuten ausschaut.
Und ich muss sagen, dass ich auch auf Spanien reden musste auf Englisch und was aber hauptsächlich bei mir was bringt, dass ich wieder MMO-Kreisel-Crime mache und dort mit einer Gruppe aus Franzosen, Italienern und Schweden spiele und ein paar Deutsche sind auch dabei und da redet man halt auf Englisch.
Natürlich redet man Gaming, MMO-Englisch, aber wir labern auch über alle möglichen Sachen und das bringt, das bringt echt was.
Wenn man einfach auf Spanien redet, dann redet man auch auf Englisch.
Wenn man einfach auf Spanien redet, dann redet man auf Englisch.
Wenn man einfach nur ein bisschen schwätzt und weiß, dass sie es halt auch nicht richtig können und man versteht sich trotzdem.
Also, da fallen einem die Wörter auch schneller wieder ein, wenn man halt regelmäßig mal ein bisschen redet.
Welches MMO wird gecrindet?
Dark Age of Camelot auf einem Free-Shard.
Eden.
Ja.
Game, was über 20 Jahre alt ist.
Aber beste Version, die es je gegeben hat.
Auf Eden.
Okay, also Leute, wenn ihr noch Stellenanzeigen habt, checkt rüber, ne?
Und falls ich sie übersehe, postet sie einfach gleich nochmal.
Okay, so arbeiten wir.
Unsere Grundeinheit, Innovativität, okay, bla bla bla, damit sie als Benchmark...
Moment, was? Moment, Moment.
Wir stellen an unser eigenes Arbeitserlebnis und an unsere Arbeitsweise selbst hohe Ansprüche, damit sie als Benchmark für andere taugen.
Ich versuche den Satz gerade zu verstehen, was mir das sagen soll.
Okay.
Okay, das, wisst ihr was?
Duck, duck, go.
GPT.
Äh, wo ist denn das jetzt?
Wo haben die das versteckt?
Hier, AI-Chat.
Los geht's.
Ja.
Was ist in einer Stellenanzeige mit diesem Satz gemeint?
In diesem Satz bedeutet es, dass Unternehmen hohe Standards an die Qualität seiner Arbeit und Arbeitsweise setzen, um als Maßstab für andere zu dienen.
Aha.
Das Unternehmen strebt also nach herausragenden Ergebnissen zu erzielen, die als Vorbild für andere dienen.
Ja, ey, das ist eine gute Erklärung.
Das ergibt Sinn.
Das hätte ich gar nicht so gut in Worte fassen können, verstehe.
Hätte man nicht sowas schreiben können, wie irgendwie, wir wollen ein Aushängeschild für an irgendwas.
Ich finde das so, so unverständlich irgendwie, was damit gesagt werden soll.
Außerdem arbeiten wir agile, lean und präzise.
Da kenne ich aber, ich kenne auch kein Precision Framework.
Okay.
Also agile und lean passt schon, aber präzise hat man sich da einfach dazu.
Forschen wir stets noch nach besseren Lösungswegen.
Okay, nice.
Akzeptieren wir, dass man dabei auch mal scheitert.
Ist mir dann immer noch der Benchmark.
Arbeiten wir mal zu Hause, mal im Büro oder auch mal remote.
Okay, ich interpretiere das mal.
Homeoffice ist in der Theorie möglich, aber für den passenden agilen Teamspirit bedeutet
das, weil man ja dafür, dass man sich nicht so viel Zeit hat, dass man sich nicht so viel
Zeit hat, brennt und Leidenschaft hat, dass man freiwillig ins Büro kommt und mit den
anderen da zusammen abhängt.
Also, eigentlich sehr selten remote und homeoffice.
Feiern wir gemeinsam Projekterfolge und lassen Kollegen ins Oh, das hört sich ein bisschen
so an, wie wir sind eine Familie.
Das ist auch immer so.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass ich es negativ meine.
Ich glaube, die meinen das wirklich positiv.
Aber für mich, der schon Erfahrung hatte.
Mal mit so einem Laden.
Der sagt, wir sind alles eine Familie und bla und hin und her, ist das immer so ein bisschen
cringe cringe zu lesen, was uns egal ist.
Wir suchen echte Entwickler mit Herzblut nicht entscheidend ist für uns daher, woher du
kommst, solange du eine Arbeitserlaubnis hast ja gut, das wäre ja illegal.
Verstehe, ob du Berufseinsteiger oder alter Hase bist, wie du dir dein Wissen angeeignet
hast, dass es auch Dinge gibt, die du nicht kannst, du Autos.
Das finde ich.
Also wisst ihr was?
So ein Abschnitt in der Art und Weise sollten mehr Stellenanzeigen haben.
Das finde ich nice, dass das ermutigt ein bisschen auch die Leute, die denken, wenn
man von zehn Punkten eigentlich erfüllt, sollte man sich nicht bewerben, was ja Blödsinn
ist, dass es auch Dinge gibt, um wie viel Uhr du in den Tag startest und produktiv arbeiten
zu können.
Deine Benefits bei five.
Irgendwie.
Hat mich der Name.
Ich habe mich gerade ein bisschen an Blue Byte erinnert.
Kennen Sie das?
Das sind die mit Siedler.
Die gibt es, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Unsere Unternehmenskultur ist von Tat, Kraft, Anerkennung und jeder Menge Spaß geprägt.
Zur besseren Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Privatleben bieten wir dir unbegrenzten Urlaub.
Das ist ein psychologischer Trick.
Das ist ein psychologischer Trick und das gibt es auch Untersuchungen zu, dass unbegrenzt
Urlaub.
Das heißt, dass die Leute weniger Urlaub nehmen.
So blöd es klingt.
Flexibles Homeoffice und mobiles Arbeiten, freie, enthaltbare Arbeitszeiten, Festanstellungen
auch remote möglich.
Okay, dann nehme ich das zurück, was ich oben gesagt habe mit liest sich nach halbwegs
immer vor Ort sein.
Ist es gar nicht.
Sonst würden sie nicht feststellen, auch remote möglich.
Wisst ihr, was eine viel bessere Formulierung wäre, die ich dann auch wirklich mal positiv
machen müsste, wenn da stehen würde.
Unbegrenzt, aber mindestens 30 Tage oder unbegrenzt, mindestens aber 26 Tage.
Das würde ich begrüßen.
Das bedeutet nämlich tatsächlich dann auch, dass man was drauf geben kann.
Das ist nämlich quasi das Gesetzliche.
Ja, so nach dem.
Darunter geht ja eh nix im Endeffekt.
Das heißt, man müsste es nicht schreiben.
Ja, aber.
Also das Gesetzliche ist was?
Es ist nicht 26 Tage.
Ja, aber.
Ich glaube, 24 Tage bei acht bei acht, bei 40 Stunden war es, glaube ich 24 also das quasi
okay, mindestens das, was es überall anders auch gibt, aber unbegrenzt unbegrenzt gibt
es tatsächlich Untersuchungen gibt es tatsächlich muss langsamer reden, kann tatsächlich Untersuchungen
zu das unbegrenzt Urlaub gleich wenige Urlaub nehmen bedeutet.
Würdest du dich darauf bewerben?
Können wir uns angucken?
Klein.
Gucken wir uns an.
Gucken wir uns als nächstes an.
Wenn wir hier fertig sind.
Okay.
Festanstellung.
Darüber hinaus bietet dir bei Five ein Gehalt, das sich nach deinen Fähigkeiten richtet
und nicht nach deinem Verhandlungsgeschick.
Okay.
Egal, was jemand auf der anderen Seite sagt, selbstverständlich richtet sich euer Gehalt
immer oder auch, wenn es mal ein bisschen mehr Kohle gibt und wann und wie oft und
wie viel immer nach eurem Verhandlungsgeschick.
Egal, was sie sagen.
Also immer.
Dein persönliches Budget für Weiterbildung und Events im In- und Ausland.
Beteiligungsprozesse auf.
Beteiligungsprozesse auf Augenhöhe.
Whatever?!
Was?
Heißt das so viel, wie man wird auch gehört, wenn man seinen Senf dazu gibt.
Ich interpretiere das einfach mal so.
Eine tolle Lage mit direkter Bahnanbindung und mindblick.
Das überprüfen wir gleich mal.
Regelmäßiges Teamfrühstück,
kostenlose Getränke, kostfreies Fitnessstudio.
Boah, okay. Moderne Büro und Technik
außer viel Geek-Charme und Authentizität.
Das würde mir tatsächlich gefallen.
Würdigung von Top-Leistung und grandiosem
Scheitern.
Okay.
Keine Politik, keine Psychospielchen.
Ich bin skeptisch, wenn sowas schon
erwähnt wird.
Ein junges Team mit familiärem
Charakter.
Ich meine, allein schon das hier
klingt ein bisschen danach, gell?
Unbegrenzter Urlaub.
Vielleicht meinen sie es auch gar nicht so.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube gar nicht,
ich will es denen jetzt nicht in den Mund legen,
was sie nicht meinen, ja?
Aber es ist halt einfach so,
jeder hat so unterschiedliche Erfahrungen gemacht.
Das ist die Art und Weise,
wie ich die Sachen interpretiere.
Und es ist ja letztendlich nach dem,
wo wir danach gehen.
Also, genauso wie unser Anschreiben
und unsere Bewerbung das Erste sind,
wo uns irgendwie die Unternehmensseite
kennenlernt, ist sowas hier das Erste,
womit wir in Kontakt kommen.
Da muss man dann halt
interpretiert jeder seine eigenen Sachen rein.
Eine offene Atmosphäre,
viel Dynamik und Respekt gegen seine Wertschätzung.
Also, ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr was ich glaube?
Ich glaube, der Laden ist nicht übel.
Ich glaube, das ist was eher Richtung
Startup,
die tatsächlich,
mit voller Begeisterung dabei sind,
du aber sicherlich
nicht irgendwie
jetzt die Welt verdienst, ja?
Wisst ihr, was wir mal ausprobieren?
Ähm,
Moment, wo hab ich denn hier?
Duck, duck, duck.
Duck, duck, go.
Ja, AI-Chat.
Ist diese
Stellenanzeige
AI generiert?
Schauen wir mal.
Chat-GPT sagt,
das ist keine AI-generierte Stellenanzeige.
Die Frage ist jetzt, Chat,
trusten wir
Chat-GPT damit oder nicht?
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die AI
generiert ist. Ich glaube,
das sind manche
Abschnitte eventuell inspiriert
aus Chat-GPT,
aber die Stellenanzeige selbst ist
handerstellt.
Ist meine Einschätzung.
Okay, also, wer Bock hat,
Byte5 in Frankfurt
sucht einen leidenschaftlichen
Frontend-Developer React.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, wo die sind.
Guck mal, sogar in der
Storage-Street.
Ah, ich wohne heute mal wieder in Main.
Okay, alles klar.
Routenplaner.
Hano, machen wir einfach mal.
Ah.
Ähm.
Mit dem...
Ja, gut. Und die ganz normale...
Die ganz normale...
Ach, das ist neben dem Hauptbahnhof.
Ist das.
Ach.
Jetzt weiß ich, wo das ist.
Das ist hier unten am Main.
Am Karpfenweg, ja.
Weiß ich, wo das ist.
Das ist gar nicht so weit weg
von da, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Okay, die haben wirklich eine sehr gute Anbindung.
Ja.
Okay, alles klar. Nice.
Chat, ich poste es euch
nochmal in Chat, dass ihr es nicht suchen müsstet.
Wenn das was für euch ist
und ihr Bock drauf habt.
So sieht es aus.
Falls du es nicht vorher schon gesehen hast.
Was denn?
Äh...
Das habe ich doch schon aufgemacht hier.
Die da, gell?
Äh, wo ist es denn? Ich sehe es nicht.
Hast du schon gepostet?
Versiox?
Achso, du hast das gepostet.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Okay, ja.
Nice.
Oh ja.
Also, meinen Senf habe ich...
Habe ich jetzt ja dazugegeben.
Ich habe schon schlechtere Stellenanzeigen gesehen.
Exzellente Hintergrundmusik.
Ah, das sind eigentlich Updates.
Ah, fuck, ich habe vergessen,
mein Sudo-Passwort einzugeben, rechtzeitig.
Okay, müssen wir nochmal kurz Package-Updates machen.
Immer her damit, Leute,
wenn ihr noch Stellenanzeigen habt.
Und auch, falls ich übersehen habe,
postet es einfach nochmal.
Was?
Adobe XD ist dead? Okay.
Why not stat? Source? Wallpaper? JPEG?
ZG.
Warum kann er das nicht?
Warum kann er das nicht statten?
Vielleicht sollte ich mal ein Clean-Bild machen.
Vielleicht geht das besser.
Wie siehst du den Markt aktuell für Junior-Fronten-Entwickler-Angular?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Entwickler.
Da bin ich zu wenig informiert drüber.
Gerade was Angular angeht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann dir allgemein sagen,
dass es aktuell gar nicht mal schlecht steht
für Quereinsteiger.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so gut wie vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr gab es gefühlt ja
an jeder Ecke offene Stellen,
die diese Probleme hatten zu besetzen.
Das ist ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Aber es gibt immer noch mehr als genug offene Stellen.
Auf jeden Fall werden mehr Leute gesucht,
als es Leute gibt.
Angular ist im Business Enterprise-Umfeld
sehr beliebt, ja.
Was hat der für Probleme, Mann?
Das Hour-Package sagt, Mann.
Das ist ein Problem.
Brauche ich Orchis-Theme überhaupt?
Benutze ich das überhaupt?
Nee, oder?
Das benutze ich überhaupt nicht.
Warum habe ich den Shit noch überhaupt installiert?
Weg damit, bam.
Piss dich, Alde.
Okay, und jetzt Reboot.
Next.
Wen haben wir jetzt hier?
Ich muss mal, Leute,
das ist mir zu plätschend.
Endend alles.
Mein neues Feierschip-Video.
Also, das ist doch schon viel, viel angenehmer.
Rhyme.
IT-System-Administrator.
Das klingt richtig schön klassisch mal wieder.
Ich sage euch doch immer wieder,
Admin-Jobs sterben nicht aus.
Auch wenn sie alle Panik schieben
wegen Cloud und sonst was.
Aber letztendlich müssen dort auch
Server und Infrastruktur administriert werden.
Vielleicht braucht man nicht mehr
ganz so viele wie früher,
aber man braucht immer noch welche.
Und gescheite Leute
wachsen da auch nicht auf dem Baum.
Gerade, weil es dort so viele alten Leute gibt,
die keinen Bock auf neue Technik haben,
ist es einfach, gescheite Leute zu finden.
Okay, IT-System-Administrator,
oh, sorry, IT-System-Administrator
bei Rhyme.
Warum ist denn das eigentlich auf Englisch?
Okay.
Als eine zentrale Figur in unserem,
in ihrem IT-Department,
wir machen jetzt, wir lassen uns dabei,
Deep L...
Eats.
Als zentrale Figur in unserer IT-Abteilung
stellen uns die Verfügbarkeit, Integrität
und Vertraulichkeit unserer wichtigsten Systeme sicher,
die für das reibungslose Funktionen,
für das reibungslose Funktionieren,
klingt ein bisschen holperig,
übersetzt von
Servernetzwerken und Datenleitungen
verantwortlich
und gestalten unsere IT-Informat...
Okay, blablabla, das brauchen wir nicht übersetzen.
Also.
Die Besten der Besten.
Your Tasks. Virtual Environments.
Man kümmert sich
um vor allem
und zwar optimale Performance
und Scalability.
Hoffen wir mal...
Ach guck mal, man kann das ganze hier auch auf
auf Deutsch stellen.
What? Das ist das ganze Gelaber
nicht drum herum.
Moment, da steht jetzt wieder was ganz...
Okay, Leute,
jetzt müssen wir uns mal beide Stellen anzeigen.
Und gucken, ob da überhaupt das gleiche
drinsteht, ja?
Also, man kümmert sich um VMs.
Ja, Virtualisierungsumgebung.
Und zwar,
da wird nicht vertikal
und horizontal, da wird sicherlich auch schon
diagonal skaliert.
Hyper wie?
Da wird's bei mir schon aufhören
an der Stelle.
Da ist schon vorbei.
Moment, Moment.
Wo hab ich das denn? Moment.
Das brauch ich so selten.
Ich hab dazu aber das passende Emote.
Auch wenn man das
heutzutage nicht mehr sagt.
Vor ein paar Jahren war das voll angesagt.
Ja.
Bruder muss los.
Wenn ich Hyper wie sehe.
Jo, Active Direct,
das wird ja immer schlimmer.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall
definitiv
nichts, worauf ich Bock hätte.
Aber da geht's ja auch nicht unbedingt krumm.
Active Directory.
Und man managt automatische
Prozesse für Windows 10, 11
Clients und Windows Server Environments.
Ach du Scheiße, Teufel.
Weiche, Alter.
VM Backup, das geht ja noch.
Das ist ja für mich so ziemlich die schlimmste
Arbeitsumgebung, die ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Active Directory, Windows Clients,
Windows Server und Hyper wie Virtualisierung.
Exchange
Microsoft 365.
Ah.
New Technologies.
You will also be actively involved in planning.
Okay, blablabla.
Boah, da hätte ich ja keinen Bock drauf.
Also für...
Ich sage nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
Ich sage nur, für mich wäre es gar nichts.
Team Spirit.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns mal die deutsche
Stellenanzeige dazu an.
Haben wir hier unten...
Ja, das ist tatsächlich die gleiche.
Der mag normal sein.
Ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Was taugt oder nicht.
Das wäre bloß absolut gar nichts.
Das wäre eine Horrorvorstellung für mich.
Wenn ich mich tagtäglich um Windows Server,
Windows Clients und Hyper wie...
Und Office 300.
Alter, ich bin der größte
Office-Hasser überhaupt.
Exchange, man, wenn ich da dran denke.
Die Stellenanzeige
hier sieht schon ziemlich viel anders aus
wie das, was die auf Englisch suchen, oder?
Hier steht einfach...
Hier ist es einfach nur ziemlich generic.
Sie gewährleisten
den IT-Betrieb,
Sicherstellung der Verfügbarkeit,
Integrität, Vertraulichkeit der Server-Systeme,
Datenleitung sowie...
Sie sind Administrator für Netzwerkssysteme
sowie der physischen Leitung.
Du bist was?
Sie sind der Administrator für Netzwerkssysteme
sowie der physischen Leitung?
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung,
was die mir damit sagen wollen.
Kabel im Fahrstuhl gerissen.
Auf geht's. Let's go.
Runde klettern.
Level-Support bei auftretenden IT-Störungen
für die Anwender liegt in ihrer Hand.
End-User-Support.
Jawoll.
Sie ergreifen Maßnahmen
zur Schaltung, Wartung und Entstörung.
zur Schaltung?
Chat, wie konkret
ergreift man
Maßnahmen zur Schaltung?
Habt ihr auch schon mal Maßnahmen
zur Schaltung ergriffen?
Die Erstellung und Pflege von Dokumentation
fällt in ihren Verantwortungsbereich.
Siehst du?
Ach so, an und aus
Reboot meint ihr.
Ach ja, okay, das kann natürlich sein.
Siehst du?
Chat, wenn ich das machen würde,
würde dieser Punkt schon mal wegfallen.
Wir wissen ja,
das dokumentiert sich dann alles selbst.
Und die Sache ist halt,
auch wenn es funktioniert, braucht man es nicht dokumentieren.
Weil wenn es nicht kaputt geht, braucht man keine Dokumentation,
weil es ja nie jemand fixen muss.
Ganz logisch.
Profil, ein abgeschlossenes Fahnen von Madigal.
Ein Tag
bei Rhyme.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich ready dafür bin.
Zehn Minuten.
Nee.
Zehn Minuten gucke ich mir jetzt
dann an.
Roboter.
Okay.
Arbeitsatmosphäre und der Vertuner sind die
Leute,
seriously, für mich wäre es überhaupt nichts.
Sagt null darüber aus,
ob sie gut oder schlecht sind.
Mich persönlich spricht es nicht an.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist.
Also mich spricht weder
die englische Variante als auch
die deutsche Variante gar nicht an.
Was haben wir dann als nächstes?
Chat, wie gesagt, wenn ihr was habt,
oder ich es gerade übersehen habe,
schreibt es in den Chat.
Okay, was haben wir
als nächstes?
Für unsere Schule suchen wir
zum 1.10. einen technischen Assistenten.
Ist das was in der Schweiz?
Der A. Huber.
Technisch, das klingt so nach
Schweiz irgendwie.
Na gut, Trier ist in Deutschland.
Das
stimmt schon. Das kann eigentlich nicht in der Schweiz sein.
Dann weiß ich gar nicht, was die eigentlich genau suchen.
Ihre Aufgaben. Unterstützung
der Schulleitung. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung,
was sie da suchen.
Für unsere Unterstützung
der Schulleitung. Okay.
Bei der
Betreuung des Verwaltungs... Das klingt nach
was extrem schlecht bezahlt wird.
Ich weiß nicht, woran ich
so... Aber mein Bauchgefühl sagt
mir, dass es unterirdisch schlecht
bezahlt. Und nervig.
Es gibt den
informationstechnischen... Ich weiß,
ich weiß, dass es das gibt, aber danach sucht
niemand.
Das wäre legit die erste Stellenanzeige,
die ich gesehen habe, die ernsthaft so jemand sucht.
Unterstützung bei der Betreuung des
Schulnetzwerkes, insbesondere Wartung und
Pflege aller digitalen Endgeräte mit unterschiedlichen
Betriebssystemen. Windows, Android, IOS.
Einbindung
der schuleigenen Endgeräte.
Zurzeit iPads, Apple TV,
Legamaster.
Man kennt's.
Das ist vielleicht wie die
Legehähne aus Battlefield.
In die unterschiedlichen MDM... Warum gibt
es überhaupt unterschiedliche MDM-Systeme?
Pflege und Wartung
der iPad-Koffer.
Technische Unterstützung der Lehrkräfte
im Unterricht bei außer... äh... unterrichtlichen
Veranstaltungen. Mitwirkung bei Planung,
Auffang, Pflege und Wartung von digitalen
Unterrichts... Das ist schon ganz schön...
Die wollen ja alles von dir
im Endeffekt.
Betreuung, Warte, Reparatur elektrischer,
elektronischer sowie mechanischer
Geräte. Insbesondere
der Kopiergerät.
Das ist so eine Art
Hausmeister-Netzwerk-Administrator.
In dem Moment.
Hausmeister
Schrägenstrich
MDM
Administrator
Netzwerk-Typ
Regelmäßige Durchführung
von Druckaufträgen
von Kollegen
und Ver...
Ist das eine Verarschung,
die Stellenanzeige?
Das ist ja geil, das muss ich mir
speichern, man.
Was sind die SysAdminSec?
SecWin bis SpecOps
äh...
Ob die auch agil arbeiten, Leute?
Die sind so...
extrem lean
und präzise.
PrintOps machen die, ja.
Beschaffung von
Materialen, Bauteilen, Kalkulation
von Kosten der elektrischen
und elektronischen Infrastruktur... What the fuck?
Mitwirkung bei der Wartung, Umrüstung,
Fliegung von Schularbeitsplätzen, Unterrichtsräumen...
Du kannst ja nur...
Du darfst doch die Wand streichen, oder was?
Vorbereitung, Durchführung von Schulfahren,
Schulfest, Abiturfeier, Unterrichts...
What the fuck?
Definition der erbrachten Leistung,
abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung im Bereich
Elektrotechnik, Elektromechatronik, IT-Bereich,
Erfahrung, Kenntnisse und Fähigkeiten bei der Betreuung
von Netzwerken, technisches, handwerkliches
Geschick, Selbstständigen und Fahndungsführer...
Alter, zur Fortenweiterbildung...
Aufgeschlossene und
Förderung mit Jugendlichen und...
No!
No! God, please, no!
Ich weiß, dass mir dort definitiv alle
auf den Sack gehen würden.
Die Schüler, aber ich glaube noch schlimmer
die Lehrer.
Identifizierung mit den Zielen und Werten der Schule.
Ich wette mit euch, Ziele und Werte der Schule
sind definitiv nicht, dass du ein ordentliches Gehalt
bekriegst. Kommunikations- und
Kooperationsbereitschaft insbesondere mit den
Hausmeistern und den für die
Netzwerk-IT zuständigen Lehrpersonen sowie
Externen für Flexibilität,
Arbeits...
Arbeitsbeginn Montag bis Freitag
7 Uhr. Bis...
Bis...
Bis fertig ist.
Es handelt sich um eine
Bundesstelle in
in die
Oh, das ist glaube ich
sehr wenig.
Entgeltgruppe 6
im unbefristeten Beschäftigungs...
Der Erholungsurlaub ist in der Regel
in den Schulferien zu nehmen.
Bewerbung mit Lebenslaufpflicht
bis zum...
Postalisch...
Selbstverständlich geht das Ganze nicht.
Okay, wir müssen mal kurz
gucken, was es gibt.
Entgeltgruppe 6
Okay, sagen wir mal, du steigst
irgendwie jemand oder so.
Moment. Also für den
für den Stress
und den Hickhack, den
oder in dem...
Ne. Wirklich nett.
Wirklich nett.
Das macht
doch niemand.
Das ist so eine typische Stelle
Das ist so eine typische Stelle,
weshalb immer geschrien wird, Fachkräftemangel.
Dieses Ding ist wahrscheinlich
seit 2, 3 Jahren beim Arbeitsamt
offen.
Niemand bewirbt sich drauf
und alle fragen sich, wie kommt es denn nur,
dass das keiner machen will.
Das ist doch eher so eine
Studentenstelle. Naja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Studentenzeit hat.
Montags bis Freitag
von 7 Uhr. Let's go.
In den Ferien
vielleicht.
Das sieht nicht so aus.
Keine Studentenzeitstelle.
Wollen da keinen Studenten haben.
Also ganz ehrlich, das klingt nach einer Stelle,
die so unglaublich abfuckt,
wenn du sie machen musst,
dass du das eigentlich noch
Schmerzensgeld obendrauf bezahlen müsstest.
Nicht nur die nervigen
Schüler. Das geht wahrscheinlich
noch. Du hast auch die nervigen Lehrer
und dass du dich ja wirklich
um jeden Scheiß kümmern musst.
Du musst sogar, das steht zwar nicht
explizit da, aber
du musst
wo steht es denn hier noch?
Hier.
Du musst im selben Fall auch die Wand streichen.
Es steht ja auch nicht immer
außer, dass sie Android und iOS haben.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
das Spektrum, was hier
abgedeckt wird, ist enorm.
Du sollst dich um irgendwelche MDM
Sachen kümmern. Windows, Android, vor allem
Windows, what the fuck?
Du sollst dich um Clients kümmern,
um Mobile Sachen, MDM,
iPad Koffer.
Du sollst dich um Netzwerk kümmern, um alle
elektronischen Geräte.
Das ist ein enorm, das ist ein
riesengroßes Spektrum.
Mit einem
also wirklich
enorm hohem Nerv
wie nennt man das?
Genervtheitspotential.
Und dann
kriegst du noch einmal was für.
Was iPad Koffer sind.
Keine Ahnung.
iPad Koffer. Mal gucken, was Google dazu sagt.
Das sind iPad
Koffer. Also, das sind iPad Koffer.
Das ist echt, also, die
Stellenanzeige ist echt der Witz.
Das macht niemals
irgendjemand freiwillig. Und wenn,
dann macht er das mit einer Motivation,
dass
du dir die Stelle auch gar nicht erst besetzen
müsstest. Also, das ist
ein Abfuckfaktor, ja.
Also, das ist ja wirklich, das ist
eine, das ist wirklich eines der
abschreckendsten Stellenanzeigen, die ich
hier seit langer Zeit gesehen hab.
Wie hieß dieses Ding? MPG?
Ah, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer
das gepostet hat.
Sonst hätte ich nämlich mal geguckt,
ob derjenige sich da
vielleicht drauf bewerben wollte.
Ja, man weiß es nicht, wer das
gepostet hat. Drauf bewerben
wollte oder
ob er dort arbeitet oder es einfach gefunden hat.
Falls derjenige sich outen möchte, der die
gepostet hat, warum hast du die
gepostet, die Stellenanzeige?
Solltest du
dafür verantwortlich sein, Leute zu finden,
dann
hoffe ich,
oder falls du da jetzt mit
mitgewirkt hast an der Stellenanzeige,
hoffe ich, ich hab dich jetzt nicht zu
sehr geflamed, aber ich
glaube, man muss das dann tatsächlich auch mal so deutlich sagen.
Klar,
mach mal, mach ruhig.
Warum nicht? Ich kann, ich kann meinen Senf zu
fast allem dazugeben. Wie viel
Mehrwert das dann wiederum bringt, sei mal
dahingestellt. Ach Leute, ich bin übrigens
ab 1.8. höchstwahrscheinlich, also
wenn ich das, wenn ich das mache,
ich bin mir aber sehr sicher, weil ich hab
die ganzen Einzelheiten durch.
Ich bin da wahrscheinlich ab 1.8. privat
krankenversichert.
1.6. Ne,
1.8. Schwachsinn.
1.8. Nicht 1.6.
Gedacht, verwirrt.
1.8. Ich hab mich
jetzt endlich dazu durchgerungen.
Und der Witz ist, ich bezahl
sogar ein bisschen weniger jetzt noch.
Falls du
einen kleinen Lacher zwischenliest, nur die Profile
Section durch. Agile Project
Manager. Nice.
Moment, haben die das rausgenommen?
Ist das eine
Debate-Anzeige, oder?
Mit durchgerungen meine ich nicht, dass
ich je gedacht hätte, dass es nichts bringt,
sondern, dass ich bisher immer zu faul war,
mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Das ist eines
der Gründe, warum ich mich
letztendlich dazu entschieden hab, das jetzt
zu machen. Ich bezahl
dann irgendwie 820
Euro oder sowas.
Und das ist
weniger, als ich gesetzlich bezahle.
Plus Rückstellungs-Sachen
und Dinger fürs Alter.
Also, die sind da schon drinnen.
Also, wenn man viel verdient,
ist gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
echt absolut pipiga.
Leider.
Ich würde ja prinzipiell
gerne gesetzlich bleiben, aber
die Versorgung ist für den Arsch
mittlerweile.
Macht man einen Termin beim Hautarzt?
Ja, dann sehen wir sie in 4 Monaten.
Bis dahin ist es entweder weg
oder mir ist, keine Ahnung, das Ohr abgefault
oder so.
Doch doch, man bezahlt im Alter schon mehr, aber
deswegen ist es mittlerweile auch gesetzlich
also Anforderung
oder erforderlich, dass man
ein bisschen mehr bezahlt, um Rücklagen
fürs Alter zu bilden.
Weil damit ein paar Richter auf die Schnauze gefallen
sind. Aber das will man
im Alter nicht, weil im Alter brauchst du ja dann
die meistens, die meiste Leistung davon.
Hast du auch eine Berufsunfähigkeit?
Ja, hab ich.
Aber keine,
selbst abgeschlossene,
sondern eine, also
über meinen Arbeitgeber.
Lufthansa Groups.
Okay,
ein Agile
Project Manager.
Ach ja, und von diesen 820
Euro, die ich bezahlen muss,
für die Krankenversicherung, bezahlt
ich glaube 360
Euro oder so der Arbeitgeber. Also das, was
der Arbeitgeber
jetzt schon bezahlt, bezahlt er ja auch.
Also bezahle ich irgendwie so knapp,
450 Euro oder
sowas, was immer noch
weniger ist.
Shorts bei deiner Berufs-, was willst du wissen?
So viele Details weiß ich da aus dem Kopf
nicht. Okay, also
ein Agile Project Manager.
Ich hoffe, der skaliert diagonal.
Alles andere wäre ja gar nix.
Schon rausgefunden,
wie groß ein Windrad ist.
Ja, die Leute
auf Twitter sind tatsächlich deutlich mehr
High IQ, als ich gedacht habe.
Deswegen hab ich da auf Twitter gepostet. Natürlich hätte ich
selbst danach googeln können. Aber auf Twitter
hat mir jemand geantwortet, der
genau wusste, was das für ein Typ Windrad ist
und die Größe dazu.
Googeln danach hätte ich selbst
können, aber ich habe ja keine Ahnung, was das eigentlich genau ist.
Ich habe aus dem Kopf keine Ahnung.
Müsst ihr auf die Abrechnung gucken.
Okay, Netcap,
ein Agile
Project Manager. Du bleibst
du, denn so wollen wir dich.
Wir
können, wir wollen und wir
dürfen auch, denn wir sind ein
Team aus hochmotivierten und qualifizierten
Mitarbeitern, denen es genauso
am Herzen liegt, Kunden zu begeistern,
wie an technischen Lösungen
zu bauen. Das macht uns einzigartig.
Wenn du dich und
unsere Produkte weiterentwickeln
oder so. Ich glaube, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich so
pauschal gesagt, Netcap ist gar kein so
schlechter Laden.
Sie suchen einen Agile Project
Manager. Ab sofort, Vollzeit,
Karlsruhe, Wien, Klagenfurt oder
Remote. Du bist das fehlende
Bindeglied zwischen
Management und den agil
arbeitenden Fachabteilungen als Agile
Project Manager.
Project Manager sind wir hier.
Bist du dabei
eine wichtige
Stütze für diese Teams und
übernimmst mit deinem Agilen
Mindset eine,
ob die auch Agile Wake-up Calls machen
und eine Vorbildfunktion für die
Kolleginnen und das Management.
Aha.
Das ist super agil.
Bei uns koordinierst und leitest du
eigenverantwortlich die Umsätze.
Als Agile Coach
Ich denke, ich bin Projektmanager.
Bereust.
Ja.
Das würde ich auch bereuen,
Agile Project Manager zu sein.
Als Agile Coach
betreust und unterstützt
du die agilen Prozesse deiner
Kollegen und legst dabei den
Fokus auf neue Technologien.
Als cross-punktionales Team
bist du in allen Fachabteilungen
gern gesehen ein wichtiges Mitglied.
Ah, ja.
Wanted.
Also, was wollen sie denn?
In der agilen Softwareentwicklung.
Scrum.
Begriffe wie Kubernetes,
Kubernetes,
Python und Golang
sind keine Fremdwörter für dich.
Okay.
Du bist ein Organisationstalent,
stressresistent, motiviert,
du kannst nicht nur
Unternehmen,
du kannst auch
ein Team sein.
Das ist gut.
Für mich ist das
ganz wichtig,
weil das ist
ein ganz interessantes Thema.
Für mich ist es
ein sehr interessantes Thema.
Und ich möchte
heute noch
ein paar
ist jetzt weder sonderlich gut, noch sonderlich
schlecht. Das ist die
Frage, ob man da auch erstmal mit einem
Agile Landing abgeholt wird.
Ja. Nachdem
man wake-upped wurde.
Okay, next.
Machen wir den hier.
Systemadministrator bei Strato.
SAP
Entwickler.
Okay. ABAP.
Let's go.
Ich pop...
Ich mach das
mal kurz hier auf.
Kann man gleich viel besser sich angucken. Also,
haben wir ihn hier. Bei Strato.
Systemadministrator
Cloud-Virtualisierung. Voll- oder
Teilzeit.
In Berlin,
Deutschland.
Ich find das immer so geil, wie die Amis Deutsche Bank aussprechen.
Doch, Deutsch... Ich kann
das gar nicht nachmachen. Deutsche Bank.
Deutsche Bank.
Okay, also.
Werde Teil unseres Teams aus
Expertinnen und bringe
deine eigene
Expertise und... Okay.
Bla, bla, bla.
Wir suchen Personen,
die für die Administration
und... Brennen.
Alter, bitte mehr sinnlos
floskeln, bitteschön.
Wir suchen Personen,
die für die Administration und
Weiterentwicklung unserer vor allem aber sehenden Clouds
genauso brennen, wie wir
und für die der Blick
über den Tellerrand nicht nur eine hohle Floskel ist.
Aber das mit dem Brennen ist schon mal wieder so
eine hohle Floskel, ey.
Könnten die nicht schreiben, dass es begeistert
dich oder sowas? Ich find das so ausgelutscht
mittlerweile, dieses
Brennen dafür, ja.
Solange die Server nicht brennen.
Nicht nur
OVH brennen die Server.
Bei Google in Paris ist doch auch letztens
ein Rechenzentrum abgefackelt.
Die hatten aber richtig die Arschkarte.
Bei Google.
Die hatten gleichzeitig
Überschwemmung,
Stromschäden, also
Stromschlagschäden und
Brände.
Das musste er erstmal schaffen.
Wir betreiben eine Public Cloud
Plattform, basierend auf VMware
vSphere, vCloud
Director und NSX.
Chat,
wer kann mir erklären, was vDirector
und NSX ist?
Hat das auch was mit VMware zu tun
oder ist das irgendein eigenes Spezialding
von
Strato?
Kennt man das?
Ja, ich kenne auch nicht alles.
Ja, vMware
Staff für Rechenzentrum, okay.
Sowie eine größere Anzahl
Private Clouds für unsere Kunden auf
Basis von vMware vSphere.
NSX
ist Netzwerkvirtualisierung.
Aha, verstehe.
Was wir für dich tun, hybrides Arbeitszeitmodell.
Das ist jetzt alles?
Nachhaltiger
Arbeitsort in Friedrichshain.
Unbefristete Arbeitsplätze.
Arbeitsvertrag, Weiterbildung, so wie du sie brauchst.
Okay, alles nochmal.
Finanzielle Unterstützung beim
Wohnortwechsel in Höhe von
1.000 Euro.
Davon kannst du aber nicht dein Wohnort wechseln.
30 Tage
Urlaub, kostenloses Deutschlandticket.
Rabatt auf
Gyms. Mitarbeiterrabatt.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn das Gehalt
taugt, scheiß auf kostenloses Deutschlandticket.
Kann ich auch bezahlen.
Und dabei der Rabatt auf Stratoprodukte
und 1&1 Produkte.
Fahrradleasen, das haben enorm viele
Arbeitgeber mittlerweile.
Angebot zur Gesundheitsförderung
Gruppenunfallversicherung.
Grippeimpfung, Augenkontrollansuche.
Das ist gar nicht mal übel.
Mitgliedschaft bei
Plink.
Wen juckt's?
Dein Aufgabenbereich.
Entwicklung
und Administration hochverfügbarer
Systemlandschaften und Virtualisierung.
Verschiedener Größe.
Pflege der Server und Speicher.
Backupsysteme,
WM sowie der Infrastrukturkomponenten.
Betreuung der Geschäftsgründe.
Aktive Mitwirkung an der Automatisierung
des Monitors der Systemlandschaften.
Klingt ziemlich Standard nach Systemadministrator.
Was du mitbringen solltest.
Praktische Erfahrungen im Design
und der Administration von VMware-Plattformen.
Ja gut, wenn es hauptsächlich um
VMware geht, wäre es sinnvoll, sich mit
VMware auszukennen.
Erfahrung mit Backuptechnologien.
Hochverfügbares Storage-System.
Bereitschaft zur
Bereitschaft zur Bereitschaftsdiensten.
Gesondert vergütet.
Ja, da müsst ihr ordentlich was raushauen.
Automatisierung mit Ansible Terraform
Shit.
Und Shell-Skripting.
Ja, das klingt ja nach einer
guten Standardkombination.
Sichere Deutschkenntnis
und Englischkenntnis, so fühlst du dich
am wohlsten.
Pluspunkt.
Ja,
ist
eine, keine schlechte,
würde ich sagen,
0815-Stellenanzeige.
Wenn man scharf drauf ist,
ja, was
mit Virtualisierung und VMware zu machen
und aus der Nähe kommt,
warum nicht?
Ist jetzt nichts, was einen beim Lesen irgendwie in Verzückung
versetzt, zumindest mich nicht.
Ist aber auch nicht mein Spezialgebiet.
Muss man ja auch sagen.
Denke ich durchaus okay.
Was es an Kohle gibt, kann man sich
überhaupt nicht ableiten, keine Ahnung.
Müssen wir jetzt mal nachgucken, ob es da irgendwie
was gibt, wenn man hier nachsucht.
Mal bei Strato in Berlin,
was da so die Range ist.
Gehe davon aus,
erstens ist es keine Senior-Position
und zweitens, ja, so Hosting-Sachen,
Hosting-Anbieter sind jetzt nicht unbedingt
dafür bekannt, so die allerkrassesten
Gehälter zu bezahlen.
Ich denke mal, es wird schon ganz okay
sein. Ja, sehr 0815
die Stellen anzeigen, ist jetzt nicht schlecht.
Chat, was sagt ihr dazu?
Würdet ihr euch bewerben, wenn ihr
in Berlin wohnen würdet, ja oder nee?
Könnt ihr mal danach immer so ein bisschen
den Chat mit einbeziehen.
Den Job nicht remote anzubieten,
das ist eine gute Frage.
Na gut, die wollen wahrscheinlich
die Leute da vor Ort
im Rechenzentrum auch haben.
Was ich durchaus verstehen kann, weil das ist
ein Hoster, die haben sehr viel eigene Infrastruktur
und ein bisschen liest sich das schon so,
als muss er da auch mal ins Rechenzentrum ab und zu.
Cloud findest
du eher uninteressant.
Jeder was, was er macht.
Wie gesagt, wir sind uns ja alle einig, dass dieses Jahr
nee, nächstes Jahr
das Jahr von Serverlessness
wird.
Da kannst du in Berlin noch nicht mal dein Foto
davon bezahlen.
Doch, kannst du wahrscheinlich, aber bleibt nicht viel übrig.
So.
Ja.
Bin jetzt nicht so geschockt.
Als nächstes SAP-Entwickler.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was da abgeht.
Bei den ABAP-Hackermans.
SAP-Entwickler.
Versicherungsbranche.
Aha.
Quasi.
Bisschen dort, wo ich jetzt
ich mein nicht als SAP-Entwickler,
aber Versicherungsbranche bin ich jetzt auch am Start.
ABAP-Hackermans.
Was ist hier los?
Du hast dein IT-Studium
und Erfahrung SAP-Umfeld aufentwickeln.
Zudem bist du kommunikativ
und lösungsorientiert.
Dann suchen wir genau dich.
Dich als IT-Entwickler.
In der SAP-Entwicklung.
Im Rahmen deiner Tätigkeit.
Blablabla.
Unser Kunde.
Ein erfolgreiches Versicherungsunternehmen.
Sucht zeitnah.
Nicht, dass das mein Arbeitgeber letztendlich ist.
Weil wir haben auch viel SAP-Geschiss.
Ähm.
Auf dich wartet
ein spannendes Aufgabenfeld.
Nehmen du deine Kenntnisse ein.
Haben wir dich überzeugt.
Ihr habt nichts geschrieben bis jetzt,
was mich überzeugen könnte.
Dann bewirb dich noch heute
und gehe den nächsten Schritt in deine...
Da steht ja noch nichts dazu da wirklich.
Das erwarte dich bei uns.
Übernahme der Produk...
Produktverantwortung
für ausgewählte technologische
SAP-Komponenten.
Machen wir mal einen SAP-Stream.
Ne.
Ich hab keine 3 Millionen übrig,
damit man da einsteigen kann.
Konzeption und Gestaltung.
Softwareanwendung und Entwicklung.
Anpassung, Dokumentation, neue Technologien
sowie individuelle Fiori-Apps.
Wie viele
Pluginsachen gibt es
bei SAP eigentlich?
Ich mein, ich hab von
SAP wenig Ahnung.
Aber so ein paar
Buzzwords von Fiori hab ich
bis jetzt noch nichts gehört.
Ein SAP-Goal für SAP-Stream.
Das muss aber ein hohes SAP-Goal sein.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hab letztens
Dinge über die SAP-Cloud gehört.
Da muss ich kecken.
Aber...
It's a secret.
Auch wenn ich nichts unterschrieben hab.
Weiterentwicklung
der Fiori-Strategie.
Alles klar.
Mitarbeiter bei der Migration auf
SAP S
slash 4 HANA.
Das hab ich schon gehört.
Das kenn ich.
Das ist irgendeine Datenbank.
Irgendwas, was Millionen kostet,
wenn du eine größere Umgebung hast.
Abstimmung mit
Anwendungsberatern.
Ja klar, die müssen den Krempel
für 100.000 an den Mann
oder an die Frau bringen.
Ein jährliches Gehalt zwischen...
Okay, schon mal großer Pluspunkt,
dass ganz klar hingeschrieben wird,
was es für Kohle gibt.
Die Range ist ja auch,
sagen wir mal, sehr eng.
Und ich glaube,
für SAP-Experten tatsächlich
auch noch eher am unteren Rand.
SAP ist bei mir
im Kopf immer
ist abfuck, keiner will's machen,
aber wird fett bezahlt.
Eine Festanstellung direkt bei unserem Kunden.
Die Möglichkeit, innerhalb Deutschlands
bis zu 4 Tage pro Woche auch Remount.
Sehr gut.
Dass das so drinnen steht.
30 Tage Urlaub
und flexible Arbeitszeiten.
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge,
Jobrat, Fahrerskurs...
Kostenlose Parkplätze,
das ist tatsächlich, wenn man da öfter...
Das ist ein Vorteil.
Individuelle Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten.
Das bringst du mit abgeschlossenem Studium
mit IT-Schwerpunkt, Berufserfahrung, SAP-Umfeld.
Logisch. Fiori.
ABAP, jawoll, da ist es.
Endlich.
ABAP.
Verhandlungssichere, also wer das mal sehen will.
ABAP, Hello World.
Man kann nicht einfach mal
einen Hello World machen in einem Texteditor.
Das punzt bei SAP nicht.
Das ist aber, glaube ich,
ein gutes Beispiel schon.
Informatik verstehen.
Ja.
ABAP, Hello World.
Hohes Maß an Kommunikationsstärke.
Also.
Ich kann dazu nichts im Detail sagen,
weil ich von SAP keine Ahnung habe.
Für meinen Geschmack ist es...
Also.
Ich kenne halt nur
so andere Sachen, die mit SAP zu tun haben.
Und da ist das gefühlt schon
fast ein bisschen wenig.
Schwer zu sagen, kommt auch immer auf die...
Ich tue mir immer schwer zu sagen
ein bisschen wenig, weil ich weiß,
dass das ein Gehalt ist, was
wahrscheinlich sogar noch über dem Durchschnitt von Deutschland liegt.
Aber ich kenne es halt aus dem SAP-Umfeld,
dass die sich alle dumm und dämlich
verdienen, aber keiner Bock drauf hat.
Ja.
Wenn man Bock auf SAP hat, warum nicht?
38 Stunden.
Die hier unten, die Sachen lesen sich nicht schlecht.
Mehr kann ich da nicht zu sagen.
Weiß nicht, was der Durchschnitt ist.
Gerade aus dem Kopf.
Was haben wir denn jetzt?
Oh, der grinst uns aber.
Schau mal.
SAS an.
Erstmal die goldene Armbanduhr am Start.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Penetration Testers.
All Genders.
Ich weiß, wie es gemeint ist, aber
das kann man schon falsch verstehen.
Du hast eine Leidenschaft für
Pentesting, prüfst IT-Systeme und
Applikationen mit offensiven Methoden
auf Schwachstellen, zeigst den Kunden Optimierungspotential
auf. Dann bist du hier richtig.
Du hast den Wahl-O-Mat
noch nicht verpasst.
Aha, Raunheim.
Das ist doch...
Das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Da bin ich doch letztens durch...
Ne, das ist
bei Rüsselsheim. Da bin ich nicht mit dem Fahrrad durchgefahren.
So weit...
So weit war ich nicht mit dem Fahrrad.
Nein, das ist ja bei Mainz hier unten.
Ganz so weit
war ich noch nicht mit dem Fahrrad.
Also das
weiteste mit dem Fahrrad von Hanau
aus war hier mal
eine Runde um Rottgau rum.
So 60
Kilometer, 62 Kilometer
irgendwie so war das.
Seligenstadt fahre ich öfters.
Ich will demnächst mal
probieren, von Hanau nach
Seligenstadt, hier unten am Main
lang, nach Seligenstadt
zu laufen hin und zurück. 20 Kilometer
sind das. Das sind ungefähr
so 10,5 Kilometer
hin, also so 21 Kilometer
hin und zurück.
Relativ langsam.
Mal gucken, wie lange ich
brauche und ob ich es packe.
Also 10 Kilometer am Stück packe ich
mittlerweile easy.
Deswegen, das längste
was ich bisher gelaufen bin waren glaube ich 14.
Und
deswegen
habe ich die Hoffnung, dass ich das ganz gut packe.
Wenn ich langsam laufe, mal
kurze Pause machen in Seligenstadt und zurück
renne, somit ich peile
irgendwas so, sagen wir mal um
6,50
7 Minuten pro Kilometer, sagen wir mal 7 Minuten
pro Kilometer, das ist schon recht gemächlich
an.
Das sollte, sollte gut drin sein.
Vielleicht, wenn ihr wollt, kann
ich meine GoPro mitnehmen, dann
kann ich meine erste, das ist ja quasi schon
Halbmarathon Distanz mal aufnehmen.
Und daran, ok
das mache ich, ich habe hier so ein GoPro
Umhänge Ding. Hast du da dann auch
ein Ziel oder einfach so um zu laufen?
Das Ziel ist das zu packen in einer
halbwegs ordentlichen Zeit, also erstmal zu packen.
Was ist der Plan, wenn man es nicht schafft?
Ja, Pause machen zwischendurch einfach
und dann weiter.
Oder ich fahre heim. Ich lasse mich abholen.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, wenn ich das packe,
ist das echt ein Beleg
für das mit ein bisschen Übung,
das jeder schaffen kann, sowas.
Ich bin fast 40,
ich sitze den ganzen Tag vorm Computer
und regelmäßig
Sport mache ich,
also wirklich mit ein bisschen Plan
dahinter, mache ich seit letztem Jahr
im August.
Also wenn ich das packe, kann das jeder
mit ein bisschen Übung packen.
Ok, also was wird hier sonst noch
gesucht? Also Penetration Tester,
höherer
Schwerpunkt deiner Tätigkeit liegt in der Vorbereitung
von Penetration Tester, speziell ist es dabei auf
Web Applications,
Web Services, API Pentesting.
Gut, ich meine, du kannst natürlich nicht von allem,
was du an Ahnung haben.
Infrastructure und Cloud Pentesting, Mobile Pentesting,
iOS, Android, Rich Internet
Application, FAT Client.
Ja,
das ist mit Abstand mein Lieblingsclient.
Pentesting,
Reverse Engineering, Embedded Devices
und gerade Embedded Devices
würde ich sagen, ist ein bisschen
was, was irgendwie auch zu
Lufthansa passen würde.
Des Weiteren gehört auch die Planeumsetzung von
technischen Reviews, Audits, so dein, ja,
das klingt alles sehr passend.
Zudem verfolgst
du aktiv die Sicherheitsentwicklung
Technologien am Markt, ja, würde ich auch
von jedem Security Mensch erwarten.
Darüber hinaus unterstützt
du Vertriebsaktivitäten, wie zum Beispiel
Präsentation, Angebotsvorbereitung
wie die Complex. Also es mag
sicherlich Leute geben, die sowas gerne
machen, aber die richtigen
Hardcore Hackermans,
die man eventuell hofft, hierfür zu
finden, das sind nicht unbedingt
diejenigen, die so
langläufig auf sowas hier stehen.
Die haben eher keinen Bock auf Vertriebsaktivitäten,
glaube ich.
Ja. Ich glaube, Lufthansa ist
kein schlechter Arbeitgeber und ich glaube, das ist
keine schlechte, keine schlechte Stelle, wenn man
die Skills dafür hat.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Ganz ehrlich, ich sehe das
sogar noch ein bisschen anders. Die Hardcore
Hackermans, die das Skill
haben, den Skill haben, plus
sowas hier gerne machen, die haben
wahrscheinlich eine eigene Hackermans Firma
und machen super krass viel
Kohle.
Was macht man als Pentester bei Lufthansa
denn für den Vertrieb? Da steht ja da
Präsentation und Angebotsvorbereitung.
Wahrscheinlich
nehmen sie dich mit, wenn sie irgendwas
verkaufen wollen, als
Experte und du musst dann da eine gute Figur
machen. Keine Ahnung.
Benefits.
Beflügelndes Umfeld.
Das ist schön umschrieben.
Abgeschlossen.
Fundierte Erfahrungen im Umgang mit offenen
Werkzeugen. Burp. Das ist ein Proxy.
Warte mal.
Nee.
Burp ist quasi das gleiche
wie mit dem Proxy, nur dass es Burp
ist. Metasploit
Kali. Ah, Hackerman.
Da muss ich bei der Gelegenheit ja immer die Story
erzählen, dass mal bei uns
auf der alten Arbeit Leute
von der Security reingerannt sind,
weil irgendjemand sich auf einem Laptop
übers WLAN von USB Stick
Kali Linux Package Updates gemacht
hat. Die haben nur im Proxy
irgendwie gesehen, Hackerman Tools!
Werden runtergeladen. Was ist hier los?
Attacke!
Letztendlich hat der nur sein Kali
Linux aktualisiert.
Zertifizierung im Bereich offensiver
IT Security
wünschenswert. Zum Beispiel
OSCP.
Siehste, ich kenn mich in dem Bereich nicht aus. Was ist
OSP? Die PEN 200
Penetrate Attesting Certification
mit Kali Linux.
Okay.
Ausgeprägte Beratungskompetenz.
Flexibilisierung
mit sehr guter Kommunikation.
Auch auf Laptop.
Seid ihr euch sicher?
Wollt ihr nen krassen Pentest-Hackerman?
Reverse-Engineer-Dude?
Oder einen der guten
Business
Speak kann?
Ich will nicht beschreiten, dass es beides in Kombination
gibt.
Aber es ist selten.
Und viele von denen
haben ihren eigenen Laden.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob die da so
fündig werden.
Ich meine, ich halte mittlerweile
ganz gerne Presentations.
Aber ich weiß auch, dass das viele
nicht gerne machen.
Ich mache es tatsächlich mittlerweile ganz gerne.
Habe ich ja schon öfters mal
meinen Weg
zu von ich hasse es zu
ich mache es ganz gerne erzählt.
Beratungskompetenz
bezogen Reise...
Ist halt auch so ein Ding,
wo nicht jeder Bock drauf hat.
Also, ich habe die Vermutung.
Wenn die das hier wirklich ernst meinen,
bezahlen die auch wirklich gut.
Würde ich mal für sie hoffen.
Sonst werden sie nämlich niemanden finden.
Dann ist das sicherlich eine Überlegung wert.
Ich glaube, Lufthansa und auch
in dem Bereich ist sicherlich interessant.
Es ist bestimmt auch kein schlechter Arbeitgeber.
Sagt mir jetzt mein Bauch gefühlt.
Und Bauch, ne?
Habe ich genug für?
Wobei, ich habe gar nicht mehr so viel Bauch, Leute.
Was verdient?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber 100k plus würde ich schon tippen.
Wenn die das dann
wirklich auch ernst meinen,
was sie hier schreiben.
Weil die wollen ja nicht irgendjemand,
der mal Ubuntu in der VM installiert hat
oder ein .NET Programm
in einem
D-Compiler aufgemacht hat,
sondern jemand, der wirklich Ahnung hat
von dem, was er da treibt.
Ich habe Hunger, Leute. Ich muss was essen.
Ich mache euch einen Vorschlag.
Während ich esse,
machen wir den Valomar zusammen.
Weil es ist, glaube ich,
im nächsten Monat.
Ziemlich genau in einem Monat ist das, ja.
Und danach gucken wir uns die letzten zwei Stellenanzeigen an.
Oder vielleicht auch mehr, wenn ihr noch welche habt.
Wenn ihr noch welche habt, schickt her.
Ich esse jetzt was,
wir machen den Valomar zusammen.
Was haltet ihr davon?
Und wer sich fragt, was ich esse,
sieht eklig aus.
Aber, seitdem ich regelmäßig Sport mache,
habe ich festgestellt,
dass mir das wirklich gut bekommt.
Und zwar Müsli
mit Haferflocken.
Haferflocken-Müsli
mit, ja, was sind das?
Wie heißt das?
Blaubeeren sind das.
Haferflocken-Müsli mit
bisschen Quark und Blaubeeren.
Das sieht nicht so
am appetitlichsten aus,
aber es schmeckt ganz gut.
Und ich habe gemerkt, dass mir das bauchmäßig gut
bekommt und
ja,
dass man sich einen Tag später dann recht
gut
gestärkt anfühlt.
Ist das Influencer-Food?
Echt jetzt?
Ist das?
Das ist Edeka-Food.
Okay.
Der Valomar. Geh los.
Die EU soll eigene Steuern
erheben dürfen. Geh mal weg.
Ich muss schon genug Steuern bezahlen.
Please, no.
Ich muss schon so viel Steuern bezahlen, Alter.
Geht mir nicht auf den Sack.
Lasst mich lieber weniger Steuern bezahlen, Mann.
Wäre eine
super Überleitung, wäre ich von
HelloFresh oder so gesponsert.
Bin ich aber nicht.
Können wir eine Prediction
machen? Prediction für was?
Was beim
Valomar rauskommt?
Ich glaube, da gibt es 80 Parteien
oder so und eine Umfrage, eine Prediction
gibt es plus fünf Antworten.
Was soll ich denn predikten? Ups.
Wir können eine Prediction machen,
wenn ihr mir sinnvolle
Antwortmöglichkeiten
für die...
AfD ist Valomat
optimist.
Social Media haben die
schon drauf.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach.
Fahrzeuge mit Verbrennungsmotoren
sollen auch
nach 2035
in der EU neu zugelassen werden.
Ja, da bin ich dafür.
Weil es durchaus Anwendungsgebiete
geben kann, wo auch 2035
Fahrzeuge mit Verbrennungsmotoren
Sinn machen können.
Ich hoffe, wir schaffen das.
Dass es kaum noch neue Fahrzeuge
gibt mit Verbrennungsmotor. Aber
keine Ahnung. Landwirtschaft,
Baumaschinen, whatever. Es gibt sicherlich
auch 2035 noch sinnvolle
Anwendungsmöglichkeiten und
Anwendungsszenarien,
die nicht mit
elektrischen Sachen abgeleckt werden können.
Da stimme ich zu.
Die EU soll eigene Seenotreppen...
Warum?
Ich meine, es hätte
den Vorteil,
dass es eventuell...
ähm...
irgendwelche Schleppersachen
einschränkt.
Irgendwelche
semi-legalen
privaten Organisationen. Vielleicht?
Keine Ahnung. Ich überspringe das.
Da habe ich mir viel zu wenig Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Kein Schimmer.
Die Ukraine soll Mitglied der EU werden.
Das ist so eine Frage.
Da wird man vielleicht
sagen...
Wie soll man sagen? So bauchmäßig
sagen? Ja.
Fuck die Russen. Aber
ich bin tatsächlich nicht dafür,
wenn man sich überlegt,
was das für einen Stress
gibt im Zweifelsfall.
Es hat sicherlich seinen Grund,
warum die es bisher nicht geworden
sind, dass man sagt, okay,
irgendwie, dass man sich
als Ziel setzt, dass man sagt, okay,
wir gucken noch mal ein paar Jahre. Aber jetzt
unmittelbar auf gar keinen Fall.
Was heißt das?
Wenn wir ein Land, was gerade im Krieg ist,
mit einem anderen Land in die EU aufnehmen, müssen wir dann
irgendwie
Leute schicken, die gegen die Russen kämpfen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt
der beste
Zeitpunkt ist.
Also in Zukunft vielleicht
jetzt nicht.
Die EU soll vorrangig ökologische Landwirtschaft
fördern. Ja, da stimme ich zu. Finde ich gut.
In Deutschland soll der Euro
durch eine nationale Währung...
Warum? Der Euro ist eines der
nicest Sachen, die wir haben.
Nicht zu. Mein Ohr juckt.
Nein, ich will den Euro behalten.
Euro ist nice.
Die EU soll den Mitgliedsstaaten
empfehlen... Ah, okay, es war
klar, dass sowas noch kommen muss.
Lass mich mal kurz mein Müsli weiter
fordern, sonst bin ich nicht fertig.
Die EU soll den Mitgliedsstaaten
empfehlen, außer weiblich und männlich auch die
Eintragung einer anderen
Geschlechtsidentität im Pass zu ermöglichen.
Da bin ich
prinzipiell dafür. Ich werde
aber für neutral stimmen.
Weil ich denke, dass sich das die Länder selbst
überlegen müssen, ob sie das machen wollen oder nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts, wo man
so von oben herab
entscheiden sollte, weil das immer super viel
kontroverse Diskussionen gibt.
Ich bin dafür, man sollte
jedem es ermöglichen, sein
Leben so zu leben, wie er will. Und wenn das dazu gehört,
okay. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es
die, wie soll man sagen,
die persönliche Einstellung
der Bevölkerung ändert, wenn das die EU
vorgibt. Ich glaube, das ist nichts, was die EU
vorgeben müsste.
Dich zu zählen, heißt für mich auch,
da kommt dann irgendwas so nach dem Motto,
das muss umgesetzt sein bis in drei Jahren.
Also, keine Ahnung,
prinzipiell ja. Ich stimme in dem Fall für
neutral. Die Jagd auf Wölfe
soll in Regionen erlaubt sein,
in denen der Bestand dadurch nicht
gefährdet ist.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die Jagd
auf Wölfe in Regionen
also, mir war das gar nicht klar, dass das nicht so ist.
Also, in Regionen,
wo der Bestand nicht gefährdet ist.
Warum möchte man denn Jagd auf Wölfe machen?
Weil da irgendwelche Bauern Schafe haben oder sowas?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keinen Schimmer.
Ich putte mal mein Müsli weiter.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Ich kann mir dazu überhaupt keinen Reim drauf machen.
Wölfe sind gefährlich für Bauern.
In der Geschichte sind ganze Städte verhungert.
Ich bezweifle, dass wir jetzt wegen Wölfen verhungern werden.
Aber ich werde das skippen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mich da viel zu wenig mit dem Vor und Wider.
Wie gesagt, mir war bis jetzt gar nicht mal klar, dass das überhaupt ein Ding ist.
Manche jagen vor Fun.
Nee, vor Fun bin ich nicht dafür.
Da wäre ich da just for Fun.
Wölfe jagen nicht.
Beim Bau neuer Wohngebäude in der EU soll die Errichtung von Photovoltaik...
Nein, bin ich nicht dafür.
Ich halte es für keine gute Idee, solche Sachen pauschal verpflichten.
Wir sollten da hinkommen, dass es eine gute Entscheidung ist, dass jeder, der ein neues Gebäude baut, Photovoltaik drauf macht.
Aber es, sag mal, entgegen aller finanzieller Anreize verpflichtend zu machen, in manchen Fällen, finde ich nicht gut.
Beim Bau neuer Wohngebäude in der EU soll die Errichtung von...
Nein.
Mehr außenpolitische Entscheidungen der EU sollen mit Mehrheit statt einstimmig getroffen werden.
Das ist keine gute Idee.
Vielleicht liege ich da jetzt...
Vielleicht verstehe ich die Frage nicht richtig.
Aber überlegt mal.
Außenpolitische Entscheidungen, das sind ja so Sachen wie...
Keine Ahnung.
Mehr Raketen für die Ukraine oder sowas.
Wenn das nicht einstimmig getroffen werden kann, dann heißt das im Endeffekt, die Mehrheit kann was beschließen, aber die, die dagegen waren, müssen es mit ausbaden.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es in vielen Regeln...
Das ist in vielen Bereichen so, ja.
RF-Programmer, das ist mein Problem mit dem Wahl-O-Mat.
Da fehlt mir immer ein bisschen Kontext da drumherum.
Warum ist das überhaupt ein Thema gerade?
Neutral.
Was?
Der Flugzeug-Dreibstoff-Kerosin soll für Flüge in der EU steuerfrei sein.
Nee, warum?
Warum soll der auf einmal steuerfrei sein?
Die gemeinsame europäische Polizeibehörde Europol soll weit...
Nein!
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich habe die letzten Jahrzehnte erlebt, was es heißt.
Gerade in Bezug auf...
Wir müssen eben immer mehr Verschlüsselung reingucken.
Zertifikate dürfen nicht mehr generiert werden mit Open Source Tools, was da in letzter Zeit rumschwirrt.
Und jegliche dieser Sachen laufen am Ende für irgendwie Nachteile raus.
Das wird am Anfang...
Die ganzen Dinger, die in den letzten Jahren eingeführt sind, werden immer eingeführt mit...
Ja, wir machen das, um schwerste Straftaten aufzuklären.
Jeder sagt, ja gut, okay.
Und dann am Endeffekt landest du im Knast, weil du einen USB-Stick auf dem Schulhof gegeben hast, wo irgendwie neueste Musik drauf ist oder sowas.
Nee.
Die EU soll länderübergreifende, mehrsprachige Angebote...
Das...
Öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk stärker finanziell fördern.
Wenn dir das Beispiel zu alt ist, dann sag halt, du schickst deinem Kumpel über Discord irgendwas.
Wir sind die letzten Jahre über immer mehr dabei, private Chats, Verschlüsselung und sonst was in der Richtung zu unterbinden.
Umso mehr Befugnisse, finde ich, bei sowas...
Wird immer angekündigt mit, ja nur für schwerste Straftaten und dann wird das immer weiter verwässert über Jahre.
Okay, die EU soll länderübergreifende, mehrsprachige Angebote, das öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk...
Nö.
Wisst ihr, wie viel Kohle öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk bei uns kostet?
Ich glaube, wie viel jetzt?
Acht Milliarden oder was kostet das?
Alter, die bekommen so krass viel Geld.
Für Lilly Schönhauer.
Und auch alles.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass sie nicht auch sinnvolle Sachen machen, aber da ist so viel Shit dabei.
Nö.
Gibt nicht mehr Geld.
Zumindest nicht von mir.
Ich werde es eh am Ende bezahlen.
Die EU soll das Ziel verwerfen, klimaneutral zu werden.
Tja.
Nö.
Sollen sie nicht verwerfen.
Das Ziel sollen sie schön behalten.
Ob sie das einhalten werden.
Das... Nö. Sollen sie nicht.
Nein.
Bei den Wahlen zum Europäischen Parlament sollen die Parteien weiterhin frei entscheiden können, wie groß der Anteil der Geschlechter...
Moment, ist es...
Ist es wirklich...
In der Diskussion, da irgendwelche Quoten einzuführen?
Die sollen einfach fähige Leute hinschicken, Mann.
Ist ja vollkommen egal, ob die da mehr Frauen, mehr Männer, whatever hinschicken.
Die sollen fähige Leute hinschicken.
Ja, und wenn sie feststellen, unser Fähigster ist irgendwie ein Eisbär vom Nordpol, dann sollen sie den hinschicken.
Ähm, ja.
Und außerdem sollen die Parteien das...
Ups.
Die Parteien sollen das selbst entschränken.
Ja.
Entscheiden dürfen.
Ja, die... Die können das ja auch machen, die Parteien, ja.
Die könnten... Wenn manche Parteien das sagen, sie wollen das... Wollen das machen, sollen sie machen.
Aber die sollen das entscheiden dürfen.
Hm.
Die EU soll Vorgaben für die Höhe der sozialen Grundsicherung...
...neutral...
Ich denke, das müssen die Länder selbst checken, was da angemessen ist.
Wobei, dann kann ich eigentlich auch sagen, stimme nicht zu, oder?
Betreiber sozialer Netzwerke sollen frei entscheiden dürfen, wie sie mit Desinformation auf ihre...
...Desinformation auf ihrer Plattform umgehen.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Es muss auch Verschwörungstheorie-Plattformen geben.
Wer entscheidet, was Desinformation ist?
Letztendlich irgendwelche Leute, die komischen Theorien anhängen, treffen sich so oder so in irgendeinem Forum, in irgendeinem Discord-Channel.
Ja.
Die Plattformen sollten das selbst entscheiden.
Ich finde tatsächlich...
Und...
Ich lasse hier in letzter Zeit kaum ein gutes Haar...
...an Twitter.
Ich finde diese Sache tatsächlich bei Twitter ganz gut.
Wenn man sich dort Werbung anguckt, beispielsweise für irgendein irreführendes Mobile-Game, wird direkt darunter eingeblendet...
Achtung!
Diese Werbung ist irreführend, enthält kein echtes Gameplay, beziehungsweise Gameplay-Elemente, die so nicht vorkommen, und so weiter.
Ich bin eh immer wieder erstaunt, wie viele Anhänger von Verschwörungstheorien und Sachen es gibt, in einer Zeit, wo es für jeden so einfach wie quasi in der Geschichte nie vorher möglich war, sich über naturwissenschaftliche Sachverhalte zu informieren.
Ich habe den Eindruck, es wird den Leuten einfach zu viel.
Ich denke, die Plattformen sollten das selbst entscheiden dürfen.
Es wird eh irgendwelche...
...Verschwörungstheoretiker-Plattformen geben.
Da kannst du nichts dran machen.
Da weißt du wenigstens, welche es sind.
Ich gebe dir zum Teil recht, aber...
Moment.
Richtig.
Ähm...
Ein Problem mit Desinformation ist...
...der Blickwinkel.
Wer entscheidet...
...was als Desinformation...
...gilt?
Wir sind ja schon darüber hinaus, dass man wirklich nur...
...ja...
...harte...
...ähm...
...quasi bewiesene Sachen...
...einordnet, und dann sagt, okay, alles, was dagegen verstößt, ist Desinformation.
Guckt euch die ganzen Shitstorms auf Social Media an...
...ja...
...und genau bei solchen Themen...
...ist das riesengroß...
...es ist ein bisschen wie...
...muss ich mal den Bogen dazu spannen...
...bei irgendwelchen Glaubenssachen.
Das größte Problem daran ist nicht, dass irgendjemand irgendwie mal gesagt hat, das ist jetzt unser heiliger Text und sowieso...
...sondern...
...wer interpretiert das und wer sagt, wie das, was da steht, jetzt ausgelegt wird?
Wer hat die Deutungshoheit da drüber?
Und dementsprechend kann man sagen, es ist gar nicht mal so klar...
...in dem Fall...
...was das hier genau heißt.
Und...
...daswegen denke ich, die Plattformen sollten das selbst handhaben.
Es muss auch ein...
...so doof es klingt...
...ja...
...es muss auch einen Platz für irgendwelche...
...Bloodearth-Leute und sowas geben.
Ist doch okay.
Natürlich ist es Schwachsinn, dass die Erde flach ist.
Aber mir ist lieber, die machen das öffentlich auf YouTube...
...wie irgendwie...
...Top Secret.
Außerdem ist es lustig, sie anzugucken.
Dann sollen die Eltern ihren Job machen...
...und den Leuten ein bisschen Medienkompetenz beibringen.
Das ist das gleiche wie Scammen im Internet.
Scammen im Internet sind an jeder Ecke.
Wichtig ist, dass man es erkennt und nicht darauf reinfällt.
Also ich denke, die Leute, die Plattformen sollten das selbst entscheiden dürfen.
In der EU sollen mehr Flächen als Naturschutzgebiete ausgewiesen werden.
Ja, finde ich gut.
EU-Fördermittel für Mitgliedsstaaten, die Regeln und Werte der EU verletzen, sollen weiterhin zurückgehalten werden.
Klingt doch erstmal sinnvoll, oder?
Wenn eine Scheiße baut, gibt's keine Förderung.
Oder?
Mehr Naturschutzgebiete, auf wessen Kosten?
Auf meine.
Und auf deine.
Wir müssen den Scheiß am Ende eh bezahlen.
Dann passiert wenigstens was Sinnvolles mit der Kohle.
Noch mal ein Beispiel zu der Sache mit Disinformation.
Ihr habt doch sicherlich alle mitgekriegt, dass es die letzten Jahre, bleiben wir mal bei RT-Themen.
Ihr habt doch sicherlich mitgekriegt, dass es die letzten Jahre über immer wieder Diskussionen gibt um
Polizei möchte verschlüsselte WhatsApp-Chats und sowas in der Richtung lesen.
Oder nicht nur WhatsApp, also generell Messenger-Kommunikation, Internet-Kommunikation und sonst was.
Ist es dann Desinformation?
Wenn du, oder würde es unter Desinformation fallen oder Fake News oder whatever, wie auch immer man das dann nennen mag.
Wenn du auf Social Media dann hergehst und sagst, hey, ich empfehle euch hier ein Plugin für WhatsApp.
Also gehen wir mal von aus, es ist dann möglich, dass verschlüsselte WhatsApp-Kommunikation mitgelesen werden kann.
Aber man möchte das nicht.
Und du postest auf Social Media und post, ey, mit diesem WhatsApp-Plugin könnt ihr das aushebeln.
Wird das dann als ungewünschter Content gefleckt?
Also so klar ist das alles nicht.
Und es ist immer die Frage, wer hat die Entscheidungshoheit da drüber?
Deswegen bin ich bei sowas immer sehr skeptisch.
Ja, witzig ist doch, das Plugin funktioniert, aber das ist keine gewünschte Funktionalität.
Von den Leuten, die das entscheiden dürfen.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, vielleicht fällt dann sowas auch unter Desinformation.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, wenn wir uns noch ein bisschen länger Gedanken machen um das Thema, fallen uns bestimmt einige Beispiele ein, die letzten Jahre über, wo einiges von Desinformation geswitcht hat zu, heute weiß man es besser.
Man wusste es vielleicht früher schon besser.
Oder auch Themen mit.
Die sind gar nicht so klar, aber wenn man sie sagt, riskiert man irgendeinen Shitstorm auf Social Media.
Ist das dann Desinformation?
Das ist alles nicht so einfach.
Und es hängt vieles dran, wer die Entscheidungshoheit bei sowas hat.
Da muss man sich unterm Strich halt fragen, ist es einem lieber, dass Elon und der Zug und sowas darüber entscheiden, wie das auf ihrer Plattform läuft?
Oder irgendwelche EU-Politiker?
Ja.
Mehr zu sagen.
Ich traue das eigentlich allen nicht zu.
Egal, machen wir mal weiter.
EU-Fördermittel für Mitgliedstaaten.
Also das klingt erstmal für mich sehr sinnvoll.
Wer Scheiße baut, kriegt keine Förderung.
Ja, das könnte ja fast schon als Desinformation gelten.
Okay.
Chat.
Nur mal so.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob ich das sagen soll, weil das super viel Shitstorm-Potential hat.
Das ist auf Twitter.
Die letzten...
Die letzten Monate gab das ja riesen, riesen Diskussionen immer.
Aber stellt euch mal vor, wir nehmen jetzt nur mal das theoretische Beispiel, ja.
Wenn da jemand postet, dass eine Frau keinen Schwanz haben kann.
Wird das gefleckt als Desinformation?
Es ist...
Da gibt es so ultra viel hitzige Diskussionen drin.
Würdest du das als Desinformation pflegen?
Oder nicht?
Es geht nicht um persönliche Meinung und sowas.
Und die Frage ist...
Ja!
Die Frage, genau das ist die Frage.
Wer entscheidet bei, sagen wir mal so, unklarer Lage, was jetzt Desinformationen sind und was nicht?
Entscheidet das jemand in der EU oder entscheidet das der Zug oder Elon?
Kommt drauf an, wie es gemeint ist, ja.
Wer entscheidet?
Das ist doch das, wo es bei der Zentrale, wo es bei dieser Frage drum geht.
Wer hat die Deutungsworte?
Wer hat die...
Wer kann das irgendwie auslegen, ja?
Ist es...
Ist es Elon?
Oder ist es einer von der EU?
Das ist letztendlich, worüber man da abstimmt.
Und da gibt es so viele Kloppereien auf YouTube, auf Twitch, gerade zu diesem Thema.
Das ist erst das Beste, was mir jetzt eingefallen ist.
Was es in dem Fall schwierig zu sagen ist, ja.
Ich muss euch sagen, ich finde es gar nicht so übel, wie Twitter das zurzeit handhabt.
Nämlich mit dem Einblenden von Zusatzinformationen bei potenziellem Schwachsinn.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll gemacht.
Oh, Alter.
Die EU soll mehr Waffen für die Ukraine finanzieren.
Boah.
Da bin ich auch so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen.
Ich denke mir immer so, ja, scheiß auf die Russen.
Macht.
Auf der anderen Seite kostet er auch enorm viel Kohle.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Was da die...
Die beste Variante ist, die es wahrscheinlich nicht gibt.
Ich werde da neutral stimmen.
Ich werde es absolut nicht überspringen.
Weil man muss dazu sagen in der Auswertung, überspringen fließt gar nicht ein.
Neutral ist eine Antwort, die auf das, was die Parteien sagen.
Das, was die Parteien sagen, matchen kann.
Die zulässige Menge an Fischen, die in EU-Gewässern gefangen werden dürfen,
soll gesenkt werden.
Da fehlt mir jetzt der Kontext.
Wird da irgendwie Gras überfischt in EU-Gewässern?
Wenn es der Fall ist, wäre es sicherlich sinnvoll.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich werde das überspringen, weil ich absolut keinen blassen Schimmer habe.
Die Einfuhrzölle der EU auf chinesische Elektroautos sollen erhöht werden.
Also, da muss ich ja sagen, ich als alter China-Shopping-Enjoyer finde das doof.
Ich habe jetzt allerdings nicht vor mir, chinesisches Elektroauto zu kaufen.
Aber vielleicht in Zukunft, keine Ahnung.
Ich bestelle gerne Sachen in China.
Und ich fände es blöd, wenn chinesische Sachen teurer werden.
Nö.
China-Chinesen-Auto.
Vielleicht in Zukunft mal.
Die Dinger werden immer besser.
Der Markt regelt das, Leute.
Die EU soll sich dafür einsetzen, dass Schwangerschaftsabbrüche in allen Mitgliedsstrafen strafvoll...
Ja.
Da stimme ich zu.
Auch ein ultra kontrovers diskutiertes Thema.
Ich kenne das aus den USA.
Dort gibt es ja ganz viele so nach dem Motto, ähm, Schwangerschaftsabbruch gleich Mord und sowas.
In den USA ist das super krasse, vor allem so auch christlich geprägte Diskussion.
Da gibt es da so ganz viele Pfarrer, die dann in Talkshows rum...
Übrigens auch ein Thema.
Desinformation.
Egal, wo du hinguckst auf der Welt, diese Frage...
...wird es unterschiedliche Ansichten dazu geben, ja?
Und...
Wenn du bei den Amis einige fragst, sagen die, oh ja, hier ganz böse und...
Also ich bin dafür.
Das sollte überall straffrei möglich sein.
Mich graust es quasi zu erfahren, wenn ich diese Frage lese, dass das wohl nicht überall möglich ist.
Tja, das ist meine soziale Plattform und ich würde jetzt entscheiden, das ist eine Desinformation.
Um nochmal zu zeigen, wie schwierig das ist mit...
Wer hat das Sagen, was eine Desinformation ist und was nicht?
Ich habe jetzt entschieden, ich sitze jetzt in der EU und habe jetzt entschieden, das, was Chaka schreibt, ist eine Desinformation.
Also ich hoffe, du siehst das Problem und das, was ich vorher versucht habe zu erklären.
Wer die Entscheidungshoheit über solche Sachen hat.
Es sollen wieder dauerhafte...
Übrigens, das sagt auch keiner, ne?
Müssen wir hier halt auch nochmal befolgen.
Das eine extrem und das andere extrem, da geht das überhaupt nicht.
Ja?
Es geht darum, dass das prinzipiell straffrei möglich sein soll.
Das heißt nicht, dass man sagt, okay, dass eine Untersuchung vorher notwendig ist, dass eine Beratung vorher notwendig ist, dass psychologische Sachen vorher notwendig sind.
Das sagt man überhaupt nicht.
Es geht nicht um das eine Extrem oder das andere Extrem.
Es sollte meiner Meinung nach auch nicht sein, dass man heute einfach sagen kann, ach ja, mir ist es jetzt nicht mehr so danach.
Och nö.
Aber prinzipiell sollte das straffrei möglich sein.
Mit Auflagen, klar.
Dauerhafte Grenzkontrollen.
Es sollen wieder dauerhafte Grenzkontrollen...
Quatsch!
Das ist eines der besten Sachen an der EU.
Dass ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, nach Spanien fahren kann oder nach Italien fahren kann, mir keiner an der Grenze auf den Sack geht.
Na.
Will ich nicht.
Das ist eines der Hauptgründe, warum die EU nice ist.
Die Aufnahme neuer Staaten in die EU soll in allen Mitgliedsstaaten durch Volksabstimmungen bestätigt werden müssen.
Ich finde...
Die Musik ist vielleicht zu solchen Dingern nicht passend, aber...
Also, ich mag sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie praktikabel das ist.
Die Schweizer, die machen sowas ja gerne, da wird erlaufen, Volksabgestimmt.
Auf der anderen Seite hatten wir schon öfters mal Volksbefragungen.
Zum Beispiel, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch dran, Abschaffung Sommer- und Winterzeit.
Wo ein großer Teil dafür gestimmt hat.
Leider ein bisschen pepeger, weil die glaube ich alle Winterzeit oder so ein Blödsinn haben wollten.
Und es bis heute nichts passiert.
Also ich finde das immer gut, wenn man direkt gefragt wird.
Wie praktikabel das ist, keine Ahnung.
Brexit war auch Volksabstimmung, ja.
Haben sie den so hart.
Die EU soll den Anbau von weiteren gentechnisch veränderten Pflanzensorten erlauben.
Ähm...
Ist das...
Warum nicht?
Wo ist das Problem?
Ist das so diese Geschichte mit, dass dann die gentechnisch veränderten Pflanzen quasi die...
Weil die besser angepasst sind, irgendwie die normalen ausrotten und sowas.
Klingt jetzt eigentlich erstmal wie was, was ich nicht haben will.
Aber ich kenne mich damit viel zu wenig aus.
Was wäre da dran problematisch?
Wenn ich damit genau das gleiche machen kann, wie mit normalem Mais.
Ich glaube...
Das ist ein bisschen was wie...
Wir setzen Kaninchen in Australien aus.
Man wusste halt nicht genau, was passiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt gegen Frauen soll europaweit als Asyl kunden.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Urheberrechtlich geschützte Werke, zum Beispiel Fotos, Musik, Literatur sollen in der EU für nicht kommerzielle Zwecke kostenlos verwendet werden dürfen.
Alter, das wäre geil, wenn das geht.
Wow.
Kann ein Krankenwagen vorbeigedüst.
Also ich finde das geil.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Aber...
Die Sanktionen der EU gegen Russland sollen abgebaut werden.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Da würde ich erst mal instinktiv sagen, nein, stimme ich nicht zu.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sich dann mal fragen, schadet uns das vielleicht mehr, als es was bringt?
Das ist eine Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann, die ich nicht einschätzen kann.
Also mein Bauchgefühl sagt eher, nee, scheiß auf die Russen.
Aber...
Also...
Mir geht es bei so ziemlich...
Mir geht es bei so ziemlich allen Sachen darum, wie viel Kohle ich...
auf dem Konto habe.
Und ich wette mit euch, ganz viele der Leute, die sich auf Twitter immer den moralischen Highground sichern,
wenn die mal nicht mehr genug Kohle auf dem Konto haben, dann ist ihr moralischer Highground auch ganz schnell nichts mehr wert.
Deswegen sollte man sich mal zumindest Gedanken drüber machen, ob sie vielleicht mehr scheiß...
Ich weiß es nicht, ja.
Ähm...
Also ich...
Ich tendiere auch zu scheiß auf die Russen.
Soll nicht abgebaut werden.
Das was für ein Ding?
Das Erasmus-Plus-Stipendium.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Studienaustausch...
Okay.
Die EU soll Atomkraft weiterhin als nachhaltige Energiequelle einstufen.
Boah, das ist auch so ein Thema, ne?
Da sieht man mal...
Wie...
Wie na...
Oder wie viel solcher Sachen da...
Das ist auch so ein Thema.
Würde ich sagen, nee.
Sollte nicht so sein.
Auf der anderen Seite ist die Frage, braucht man es nicht vielleicht trotzdem?
Die Frage, ob man das mit allen...
Ob man das mit alternativen Energiequellen alles hinbekommt.
Und man fragt sich halt auch, ob das wirklich sinnvoll ist, wenn wir sagen jetzt zum Beispiel...
Aber es geht ja hier um die EU, ja.
Wenn wir in Deutschland sagen, ey, wir machen das...
Wir machen das nicht mehr, kaufen das dann aber woanders, wo es mit Atomkraft hergestellt wird.
Whatever, also...
Atomkraft kann Erneuerbare nicht ergänzen.
Warum nicht?
Mal ernst gemein jetzt, warum nicht?
Klingt doch eigentlich sinnvoll, oder?
Warum...
Warum geht das nicht?
Kacke für Stromnetz?
Warum?
Also, dass uns irgendwie das Uran ausgeht, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Aha, okay.
Klingt einleuchten, ja.
Klingt einleuchten.
Das ist korrekt.
Atomkraft...
Hier geht's um Kernspaltung.
Andersherum kann ich's mir nicht vorstellen.
Weil Fusion ist ja noch nicht wirklich marktreif.
Wie soll man das umschreiben?
Ist das so ein Ding? Theoretisch ja.
Praktisch gebaut? Nee.
Ist das nicht so ein Meme unter Fusionsforschern?
In 30 Jahren ist das einsatzbereit?
Okay, ähm...
Nein.
Die Einwanderung von Fachkräften in die EU soll vereinfacht werden.
Ja.
Wenn wir von Fachkräften reden, die wir in Gebieten, die wir brauchen, find ich das nicht schlecht.
Die Frage ist, wer zählt als Fachkraft?
Also, wir hatten die letzten Jahre über ja schon genug Probleme in dieser Richtung.
Prinzipiell ja.
An der Umsetzung wird's wahrscheinlich scheitern.
Also, wenn wir...
Das Problem ist...
Also, glaube ich zumindest.
Dass viele Fachkräfte...
Die wirklich...
Fachkräfte sind, die haben gar keinen Bock.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich hab mal ein Video gesehen, da war da Lindner an irgendeiner Uni in Afrika oder so.
In Südafrika.
Ich glaube in Südafrika, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaube es war in Südafrika.
Kann aber auch ein anderes Land gewesen sein da unten.
Und da hat er einen Vortrag drüber gehalten.
Wie geil es ist in Deutschland zu arbeiten.
Und am Ende hat er gefragt.
Wer von euch oder wer von ihnen könnte sich das vorstellen?
Quasi als Fachkraft nach Deutschland zu kommen.
Hat sich keiner gemeldet.
Die hatten alle keinen Bock.
Die wollten alle nicht.
Also, rein wenn man mal nur die Frage so wertet, wie sie da steht.
Und mal ausplänen, mit was wird denn da draus gemacht.
Finde ich, würde ich dem prinzipiell schon zustimmen.
Also, wenn das bedeutet, wir suchen uns wirklich die Leute raus, die wir brauchen.
Dann bin ich dafür.
Ja, aber niemals so kontrollierbar.
Naja, könnte man sicherlich, ja.
Und du brauchst halt einen nachgewiesenen Abschluss.
In Sachen, die wir brauchen.
Du kannst das sicherlich ordentlich überprüfen.
Wem du da die Green Card gibst und wem nicht.
Wenn man das ordentlich überprüft.
Wenn man gewillt ist, das ordentlich zu machen, kann man das bestimmt.
Ich stimme der Sache zu.
Unter den Voraussetzungen, die ich gesagt habe.
Wird doch jetzt auch nicht gemacht.
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Also, wenn es wirklich so gemacht werden würde, dann bin ich dafür.
Die Beteiligung außereuropäischer Investoren an Unternehmen im Bereich kritischer Infrastruktur soll in der EU stärker beschränkt werden.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich glaube, hier muss ich echt meinem.
Meiner.
Meiner anderweitigen Einschätzung mal entgegenläufig abstimmen.
Ja, da bin ich dafür.
Weil ich, weil ich keinen Bock habe, dass irgendwelche China Chinesen.
Bei uns.
Häfen besitzen und sowas und da machen können, was sie wollen.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt ja wieder sagen, der Markt regelt das.
In dem Fall würde ich sagen, das muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ja.
Der Präsident beziehungsweise die Präsidentin der Europäischen Kommission soll von.
Oh ja, da bin ich dafür.
Da sitzt da vielleicht irgendjemand, auf den ich Bock habe.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht, weil dann immer nichts Gescheites zum Aufstellen gibt.
Aber ja, da bin ich dafür.
In der EU sollen Unternehmen mehr für den Ausstoß von CO2 bezahlen müssen.
Mehr als woanders.
Oder wie?
Warum?
Sollen was dafür bezahlen müssen?
Ja.
Aber man sollte es jetzt nicht.
Einfach komplett übertreiben, sodass keiner mehr hier irgendwas wirtschaftlich machen kann.
Mehr als jetzt.
Ich finde, es sollte Anreize geben.
Und keine.
Irgendwelche Vorgaben.
Also.
Es ist schwer zu sagen, ich kenne mich auch zu wenig in dem Bereich aus.
Ich tendiere eher zu Nein, stimme ich nicht zu.
Weil letztendlich müssen wir den Scheiß bezahlen.
Es macht alles wirtschaftlich problematischer.
Vermutlich.
Und außerdem gehen die dann in Zweifelsfall keiner nach Bangladesch und bauen da ihren Kram hin.
Und stoßen auch nicht weniger aus.
Ich...
Ich stimme nicht zu.
Asylbewerberinnen und Asylbewerber sollen ihren Antrag vor Überschreiten der EU-Außengrenze stellen müssen.
Und dort auf das Ergebnis warten.
Das finde ich eine sinnvolle Variante.
Ja.
Das wurde ja schon vor Jahren vorgeschlagen, mal sowas in die Richtung einzuführen.
Da wurde das nicht weiter verfolgt.
Ich habe damals schon nicht so genau verstanden, warum nicht.
Weil dann hast du nicht das Problem, dass wenn die Leute erstmal am Start sind, dass du sie niemals wieder los wirst.
Ja.
Das klingt sinnig.
Die EU soll weiterhin in gemeinsame europäische Rüstungsprojekte investieren.
Ja.
Das ist, denke ich, tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll.
Wir haben gesehen, dass es Probleme mit Russland gibt.
Ähm...
So blöd es ist...
Ich sag mal so.
So schön die Welt wäre, wenn man es nicht brauchen würde, so sehr sieht man, dass man es doch braucht.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn man sagen würde, ey, wir geben für ganz schön viel Geld für Militär und Polizei aus.
Wäre es nicht geil, wenn wir das sonst sparen können?
Das Problem ist, du hast halt immer ein paar Leute, die finden es halt geil, wenn es keine Polizei mehr gibt.
Und sie ihr Zeug treiben können.
Deswegen ist...
Die Realität und Wirklichkeit passen halt nicht zusammen.
Aber ich glaube, man sieht aktuell, dass es doch nicht so friedlich auf der Welt ist, wie wir das gerne hätten.
Deswegen hier gut vorbereitet zu sein, ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Wie soll denn...
Per Fax natürlich.
Mit Fax.
Mit was denn sonst?
Deutschland geht sowas nur per Fax.
Ähm...
Das Europäische Parlament soll weiterhin eine zentrale Rolle...
Ja, da würde ich tatsächlich zustimmen, weil...
Was sonst?
Okay.
Gewichtung der Thesen.
Wir gewichten gar nichts.
Wir lassen uns einfach default.
Alle.
Bin mal gespannt, was da dann rauskommt.
Ihr Wahl-O-Mata-Games.
Die Basis.
Die Basis wurde im Umgang...
Die Basis wurde im Umfeld gegen staatliche Maßnahmen der Covid-Pandemie gegründet.
Ach du Scheiße, Mann.
Der 5G-Technologie, den sie kritisch gingen.
Scheint aber sonst ganz brauchbare Ansichten zu haben, oder?
Gagalo.
Damit hätte ich wirklich nicht gerechnet, Mann.
Dass mein bester Match irgendwelche 5G-Gegner sind, Mann.
Ach du Scheiße, Alter.
Die Partei.
Ah, am Start.
Okay.
FD...
Was?
PDF.
Die Partei des Fortschritts.
Aha.
Bündnis Deutschland.
B...
Wer ist das?
Ach, die.
Okay.
Menschliche Welt.
Moment, die Piraten.
Gibt es noch?
Die habe ich früher öfters gewählt.
Also, als die noch gab, irgendwie.
Freie Wähler.
Der Mann.
Der...
Der Markt regelt das.
Hätte mich auch gewundert, wenn die nicht weiter oben mit am Start sind.
Der Markt hat geregelt.
Die Linke.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich so viele Zustimmungen mit denen habe.
Okay.
Tierschutz hier.
Ja, das ist doch wenigstens etwas, was ich unterschreiben würde.
Was das heißt?
Oh, nein.
Nur 65% Linke...
Twitter...
Twitter-Shitstorm.
Eshaft jetzt?
Bei...
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich hätte bei einer Partei Tierschutz als letztes an sowas gedacht.
Wie kommst du da drauf, dass das so ist?
ÖDP.
Ökologisch-Demokrat...
Was es alles gibt, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Familie, Heimat, Meer...
Letzt...
Die sind auch am Start.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es die da jetzt als Partei...
Dass es die jetzt auch als Partei gibt.
Tierschutzpartei.
Klimaliste.
Na gut, hier unten ist er.
Guck mal.
AfD ist auch ganz unten mit am Start.
Ja.
Da...
Die Punkte habe ich bestimmt gesammelt mit...
An der Grenze bereits den Antrag einreichen.
Okay.
Also, Leute.
Ich muss die...
Ich...
Ich muss die 5G-Leugner...
Äh, nee.
Die 5G-Keck-Alu-Leute wählen laut dem Wahl-O-Mat, Mann.
Da hätte ich echt...
Da hätte ich echt nicht mit gerechnet, ey.
Dass ich auf...
Dass die weiße Zustimmung irgendwelche Anti-Technologie-Typen sind, ey.
What the fuck.
Richtig Keck-Alu, Mann.
Die mögen auch nicht Bill Gates.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das passt ja zu dem.
Ja, nicht zwangsläufig.
Ähm.
Nicht zwangsläufig.
Ich meine...
Es geht ja um EU-Grenze.
Nicht um Landesgrenze.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass sie nicht woanders hin können.
Ja, aber...
wo es erstmal safe ist
und dort dann den Antrag stellen.
Also da gibt es keine wirklich
perfekte Lösung.
Irgendjemand fällt leider immer hinten runter.
Und wenn man es selbst ist.
Was ist Mera25? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung. Gemeinsam für
europäische Unabhängigkeit.
What?
Alter, hör mir auf.
Es geht mir so am Arsch vorbei.
Ich wusste bis zu diesem
Zeitpunkt, wo auf Twitter
geschitzt worden wurde, mit Aron Gracht
wäre Anni the Duck überhaupt. Oder Annie?
Weiß nicht mal, wie man die ausspricht.
Ich wusste mit Aron Gracht erstmal, wer das überhaupt ist.
Irgendjemand ist da
auf Twitch streamt.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht. Ich weiß übrigens immer noch nicht genau,
was das Problem ist. Ich habe mich damit null beschäftigt.
Ich will es auch gar nicht wissen.
Ich glaube, sie hat gesagt, ihre Fans stinken und sie mag
ihre Fans nicht. Was ich voll und ganz
verstehen kann. Ich würde die meisten Fans
da aber sicherlich auch nicht mögen.
Und ansonsten
wahnsinnige Überraschung.
Influencer behaupten
Dinger, um gut dazustehen, stehen aber
nicht dahinter. Wer hätte das
nur denken können? Niemals.
Niemals hätte man da drauf
kommen können. Nie.
Das ist alles immer schon so super
authentisch und immer glauben...
Ganz genau. Ich weiß
auch nicht, was da abgeht. Und das Statement
habe ich mir nicht angeguckt,
weil mich schon das ursprüngliche
Problem... Oder was heißt Problem?
Das ursprüngliche
Ärgernis für viele Leute,
ging mir schon am Arsch vorbei.
Und das jetzt geht mir noch mehr am
Arsch vorbei.
Was ist PTBS?
Und ist das wirklich was,
was irgendwelche
öffentlichen Leute, die nicht dabei waren
auf Twitter jetzt alles so
genau wissen und einschätzen und
dazu was sagen müssen, ja?
PTSD, ja.
Der einzige Grund,
warum da jeder drauf reactet ist,
weil das
im Prinzip genau das gleiche, weil das Kohle, äh,
ja, na Kohle, sagen wir mal,
Exposure
bringt.
Indirekt Kohle.
Soll ich noch was sagen? Es ist mir
sowas von scheißegal,
wer da mit wem irgendwas
hatte, wer da wen irgendwie
beschissen hat, es ist mir sowas von
egal. Ich gebe
zu, einen gewissen Unterhaltungswert haben
diese Influencer-Beefs immer
so am Rande mitverfolgt.
Was ich auch immer super unterhaltsam
fand, die letzten, äh,
Monate, war
diese Geschichte
Shoryoka vs. KuchenTV,
da musste ich mich auch öfters wegkecken,
wenn ich da manche Sachen zu gelesen hab.
Also,
ja, es stimmt, ein bisschen,
gewissen Unterhaltungswert hat
dieser ganze Kram schon.
Ähm,
aber
nicht genug, als
dass ich mich im Detail
mit der ganzen Sache zu sehr beschäftigen
will. Was ich besonders
lustig an dieser anderen, an dieser
KuchenTV vs. Shoryoka Sache
fand, ist,
dass sie sich auch
gegenseitig verklagt haben.
Wo dann immer wieder
kam, jetzt kam ein Brief
vom Anwalt,
dann kam das nächste Video,
ich hab Post vom Anwalt bekommen.
Mein Anwalt hat jetzt drauf
geantwortet. Dann kam wieder ein Video,
drauf.
Post vom Anwalt.
Oh Mann.
Ja, der gönnt sich richtig mit
sowas, ey.
Ja, ihr habt recht,
einen gewissen Unterhaltungswert hat der ganze
Influencer-Brief-Kram schon.
Aber mich interessiert es nicht,
nicht genug,
dass ich mir das im Detail angucken will.
Und, also was ist hier?
Ohne
darüber mich im Detail informiert zu
haben.
Aber dass Influencer
vor der Kamera gut Wetter machen
und hintenrum sich
kacke verhalten und
vielleicht nicht die Menschen sind,
die man gerne in ihnen sehen möchte,
ist wirklich echt
nichts Neues.
So.
Ich bin fertig essen, können uns jetzt die
restlichen Stellenanzeigen angucken.
Ah, noch zwei, äh, drei Stück.
Vier Stück. Das hatte ich doch schon, oder?
Wer weiß.
Aber,
nachdem das hier meine Plattform
ist, kann ich einfach als
Desinformation flaggen, was ich will.
Und,
das ist natürlich alles faken just dann.
Ja, vielleicht bin ich auch
Agile Coach, das könnte sein.
Also, let's go.
Was haben wir hier? DevOps-Engine.
Das ist mir auf jeden Fall schon mal viel zu hell, diese Seite.
Und, das erste, was mir auffällt ist,
die haben viel zu viele Anzüge an.
Was ist da los?
Als DevOps-Engine, die sehen, die sehen,
die sehen viel, viel, viel, viel zu
Business Enterprise aus.
Scheint ja nicht so richtig menschlich zu sein, ne?
Die Mensch, die menschliche Welt.
Der Typ im Hintergrund ist doch aus
Mr. Robot.
Du meinst den, ne?
Äh, vielleicht ein ganz
kleines bisschen, ja?
Vielleicht ein ganz kleines bisschen.
Äh, äh,
von der Frisur vielleicht ein bisschen.
Wie hieß dieser, wie hieß denn der Typ bei Mr. Robot?
Der, ähm,
der Manager, der ein bisschen IT-Ahnung
hatte.
Wo sie leider meiner Meinung nach das Ende von
Season 1 voll verkackt haben.
Der, der Elliot am Anfang gefragt hat,
benutzt du schon Gnome oder
noch KDE oder irgendwie so komisches
Zeug. Warte mal, Mr. Robot,
KDE. Das, dieser
Dialog hat so keinen Sinn gemacht,
aber, ja.
Ja.
Oh, hi.
Tyrell Willick.
Tyrell!
Hello.
Elliot.
Just attacked.
Don't be so humble.
You know, I started out exactly where you are and
to be honest, you know, my heart is still there.
So I see a running Gnome.
You know,
I'm actually on KDE myself.
I know this desktop
environment is supposed to be better, but
you know what they say.
Old habits, they die hard.
An executive running Linux?
Yeah, I know what you're thinking.
I'm an executive, I mean,
why am I even running Linux?
Again, old habits.
Eigentlich kann die Firma gar nicht so schlecht
sein, wenn man, wenn sie freie
Betriebssystem, wenn sie freie
Betriebssystemwahl hat.
Okay.
Also, da
sind wir hier am Start.
Ja, ein bisschen vielleicht.
Für unsere Abteilung
in der Information im Standort haben, suchen wir
einen DevOps Engineer, MWD in Vollzeit.
Ihr vielfältiges
Aufgabengebiet umfasst unter anderem
Management und
Optimierung von Tools, Standards
und Prozessen in der Automatisierung
von Bereitstellungsprozessen.
Develop,
Build and Run. Aha.
Deployed wird
nicht. Das ist
nicht im Scope.
Lösung neuer technischer
Herausforderungen in der Softwareentwicklung.
Ausstelle zwischen IT-Infrastruktur, IT-Anwendungsentwicklung,
aktive Mitwirkung in klassischen oder agilen
IT-Projekten. Okay, das ist sehr
nichtssagend.
Was machst du die ganze Zeit mit der Uhr?
Du machst das hier. Das ist mein
Pro-Hackerman-Move.
Ihr Profil. Abgeschlossenes
Moment mal, ich mach mal die Musik an.
Abgeschlossenes Studium der
Wirtschaftsinformatik oder eine
vergleichbare Ausbildung.
Oh.
Praktische Erfahrung im Aufbau von
DevOps-Umgebung. Ah, das ist hier
genau meins.
Ich hab schon
DevOps gemacht, bevor es das Wort
DevOps gab.
Boomer Talk.
Praktische Erfahrung in der Softwareentwicklung.
Ich hab vor allem Erfahrung im entwickeln
fehlerfreier Software.
Wie man hier sieht.
Keine Bugs.
Hier mal eine Stelle.
Moment.
Sind das nicht die
Abmahnkanzlei?
Ne, die guck ich mir aus Prinzip nur hier im Stream an.
Alles Anwenderfehler.
Korrekt.
Sicherer Umgang im
Source Control Management.
Shit. Shitlab.
Und CI
Jenkins Gitlab
JFrog Artifactory.
Ich kenne witzigerweise alles.
Und ich mag Jenkins.
Auch wenn Jenkins für viele oldschool
ist. Irgendwie hab ich ein
Herz für Jenkins.
Genauso wie ich beim Monitoring ein Herz für Nagios
hab. Auch wenn ich keinen neuen Nagios mehr installieren möchte.
Praktische Erfahrung im Einsatz
von Ansible. Ja, passt da gut dabei.
Erfahrung
in der Bereitstellung
von Containern Docker
Kubernetes.
Wir müssen alles cool aussprechen,
dass wir auch hier als Experten rüberkommen.
Deswegen Chat.
Wie sprecht ihr
das hier aus?
Wie wird das hier ausgesprochen?
Jason?
An
Jason denkt keiner, oder?
Warum
nicht Jason?
Das ist das, was du meinst, okay.
Sogar der
Jason-Erfinder sagt, es wird
Jason ausgesprochen.
Wobei er das glaube ich nur...
Ich weiß nicht, ob er das wirklich ernst gemeint hat.
Erfahrung im Monitoring
Grafena... äh Grafena.
Grafana.
Prometheus.
Oder wie die Amis sagen, Prometheus.
Erfahrung mit Datenbanken. Oracle,
Postgres, Exasol.
Ich hab legit kein
schimmer, was Exasol ist.
The In-Memory-Database.
Built for Analytics. Okay. Kennt das
jemand von euch? Nie gehört.
Erfahrung im Datenbank-Refactoring.
Versioning. LiquiBase.
Flyway kenne ich.
Aber Liqui... wahrscheinlich das gleiche.
Ausgeprägtes analytisches
Denkvermögen und konzeptionelle
Fähigkeiten. Starke Kommunikationsfähigkeit,
Teamfähigkeiten, Eigeninitiative.
Wer sind wir?
Wir sind eine unabhängige Privatbank
mit Hauptsitz in Hamburg. Ja, schön
für euch. Müssen wir jetzt nicht durchlesen.
Was uns von Größerem...
Das individuelle Betreuen unserer Kunden
sehr gut im Arbeitsklima, unserer überschaubaren
Unternehmensgröße... Okay.
Eine Sache, die mir tatsächlich schon mal positiv
auffällt, ist,
dass das, was sie suchen
und das, was sie schreiben,
ziemlich gut übereinstimmt.
Das ist ja auch nicht
gegeben bei jeder Stellenanzeige.
Das heißt, das ergibt schon mal
in sich konsistent so geschlossen
irgendwie Sinn. So.
Wir bieten attraktive Vergütung.
Ja, dann sag doch mal. Sag doch mal
eine Hausnummer. Ich finde das immer so geil.
Überdurchschnittliche Vergütung.
Ein überdurchschnitt... oder
marktübliches Gehalt. Attraktive
Vergütung. Ja, was denn? Sagt halt mal was.
Und sei es nur eine Range. Sei es nur
eine Range. Sagt halt mal was.
Attraktive Vergütung kann jeder sagen.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten
und mobiles Arbeiten.
Schön, dass es da steht.
Mobiles Arbeiten vor allem.
Mobiles Arbeiten ist
der Überbegriff, wo
unter anderem Homeoffice auch drunter
fällt. Also, ich meine, es sind zwei
unterschiedliche Varianten.
Aber viele Unternehmen haben eine
mobile Arbeiten-Regelung, wo dann
Homeoffice auch drunter fällt.
Zentral gelegene Arbeitsplatz
mit optimaler Anbindung an
die öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel.
Glaube ich Ihnen jetzt
einfach mal. Individuelle Förderung,
blablabla. Dreistag Urlaub,
Weihnachten, Silvester frei. Kommt das dazu?
Oder musst du den Urlaub nehmen?
Ich würde mal sagen, zusätzlich. Betriebliche...
Also, bei uns ist es auch so. Weihnachten, Silvester ist zu,
da musst du ja keinen Urlaub nehmen.
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge und
vermögenswirksame Leistungen.
Dienstrad-Leasing.
Das haben auch sehr viele Bezugs- und
Mittagessen...
Es ist echt ein großer Vorteil,
eine Kantine drinnen zu haben,
die subventioniert wird.
Vor allem, wenn das Essen gut ist.
Das ist echt ein Vorteil.
Bin ich gar nicht übel.
Weiß nicht, ob derjenige noch am Start ist.
Ich finde jetzt gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so,
wo ich sage, beste Anzeige, die ich hier gesehen habe,
aber finde ich
geht klar.
Sieht man noch, wer es gepostet hat?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Ich finde, geht klar.
Next.
ZEF-Desk. Echt?
Keine Ahnung.
War das eben nicht noch auf Deutsch?
Okay.
Also.
ZEF-Desk.
Intuitive Cloud Accounting
Software.
Blablabla.
Your Mission.
Sie suchen einen Technical Lead
Frontend JavaScript React.
Ein Tech Lead
im Frontend Development.
Focus on Web Development.
Hätte ich jetzt in das erste, ehrlich gesagt,
schon reininterpretiert.
Your Mission is to drive
the conversion of potential
Customer... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist ja der krasseste
Business-Speak aller Zeiten, Alter.
Your Mission
is to drive the... Ich dachte
eigentlich, du bist Technical Lead für Frontend
Entwicklung und nicht irgendwelche
Leute zu überzeugen, den Scheiß zu kaufen.
Das sind jetzt
zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, die ich da...
Egal. Aber das ist ja mal hier.
Your Mission is to drive the conversion
of potential customers to
various marketing touchpoints
ensuring they are
convinced of the product to the extent
that they are willing to initiate a trial phase...
Also im Prinzip wollen die einen
Frontend Tech Lead Entwickler, der aber
gut verkauft?
Oder wie?
Oder was...
Oder wollen die, dass
der sich drum kümmert, dass man
eine gute...
Wie nennt
man das? So eine gute...
Wie heißt das denn, wenn man
so eine Art Landing Page oder sowas?
Ja, genau.
So eine Art Landing Page
bauen, dass die Leute Bock haben,
sich das weiter anzugucken.
Und du brauchst natürlich das passende
Grindset-Mindset, sonst geht da gar nichts.
Okay.
So macht man Impact.
Man
actively contributed
to the continuous
improvement and optimization of our website.
Okay. Also.
Man erweitert
und programmiert an der Website
herum. In Ordnung.
Du hattest auch noch eine, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich die heute alle noch
durchkrieg.
Man supportet die Marketingleute
mit
dem Webflow...
Mit der Web... Was? In
Managing our Webflow-based
Website and integrate our custom
Toolkits.
Also man macht
ein bisschen Support für
die Marketingleute.
Dass sie in ihrem
Content-Management-System
da Dinger machen können oder so.
Whatever.
Man
wartet und
verbessert existing tracking
Setups. Tracking-Setups meinen die wahrscheinlich sowas wie Google Analytics
in der Richtung vermutlich.
Oder?
Was ist mit Tracking-Setup
in dem Fall gemeint?
Ja, indem man seine
High-IQ super krasses Knowledge
nutzt, was Rest-APIs angeht.
Whatever das damit zu tun hat.
Und NoSQL
Databases like MongoDB.
Ja.
Okay.
Man hilft dabei, interne
Marketing-Tools zu verbessern.
Content-Management. Hier kann ich
aber nicht merken, was es heißt. Tracking-Systeme.
Man übersetzt
von Nicht-Technik-Leuten
zu Technik-Geschichten.
You implement Marketing-Technology.
Tech-Management-Systems. Tracking-Systems.
JavaScript-Schaukel.
Du bist halt im Endeffekt ein Frontend-Entwickler.
Der sich noch um
bisschen anderen Kram
mit kümmert.
Okay, man ist besonders passionate
für Coding und
möchte da mitarbeiten.
High-Quality, Efficient,
Code-Delivery. Okay. Alles klar.
Was soll man denn können?
Fünf Jahre
Erfahrung in modernen
JavaScript-Frameworks, wie zum Beispiel
Gatsby, Next...
Gatsby nicht so ein Blogging-System?
Ah, ne. Das ist React.
Was meine ich denn für
ein Blogging-System? Das heißt doch...
Ich meine nicht Hugo. Es gibt doch noch
ein anderes. Ist das nicht so ähnlich?
Dann weiß ich nicht.
Okay, Next.js, Express.js.
Also einfach nur sagen...
Express.js ist alles, bloß nicht neu.
Okay, sie sagen auch modern.
Or Node.js.
Wait a minute. Leute, Leute.
Ma... Ma... Ma... Ma...
Step back. Nur weil es
JS am Ende hat, ist Node.js
ganz was anderes als Next.js
und React und Express.js und so.
Das sind alles JavaScript-Frameworks.
Das ist JavaScript-Runtime.
Da ist zwar auch JS am Ende.
Ist aber was komplett anderes.
Was ist denn Webflow?
Ja, so ganz genau check ich das
auch nicht. Ich vermute
mal, dass die halt irgendwelche
internen Marketing-Tools haben.
Vielleicht irgendwie mit so
irgendwelchen Workflow-Sachen
zum Durchklicken und
ja, da sollst du denen helfen bei...
Ghost, meine ich? Ghost?
Das kann sein, ja.
Also, eins muss man ja bei denen echt lassen.
Tracking
ist denen enorm wichtig, oder?
Tracking kommt irgendwie in
jedem zweiten Satz vor.
Ja, man kennt
sich aus mit Cookie, mit diesen
Zustimmungs-Cookie, Zustimmungs-Bannern,
Tracking-Scripts
und A-B-Testing.
Aha.
Ja.
Webflow ist eine No-Code
SaaS-Website-Builder.
Okay, nie gehört.
Jetzt wissen wir es.
Also, A-B-Testing.
Heißt so viel
wie, man macht
zwei Webseiten-Versionen und
dann lässt man
ja,
wie auch immer, überprüfen
welche besser performt.
Das hatten sie schon mal.
Man soll fluent in German und Englisch
sein,
damit nahtlose Kommunikation mit dem
Team und across Departments
gewährleistet werden kann.
Kotlin, Spring Boot,
JavaScript, React, REST,
Docker,
SQL, AWS, Terraform. Tatsächlich ganz
interessant. Guck mal hier.
Das dürfte, glaube ich, vielen
Enterprise
Programmers
gefallen.
Viele Java-Entwickler stehen auf
Spring Boot, nur viele Java-Entwickler
stehen eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig auf Java.
Und die Kombination
aus Kotlin
und Spring Boot könnte, könnte ich mir
zumindest vorstellen, in diesem Ökosystem
tatsächlich einige
ansprechen.
JavaScript ist klar, weil Frontend,
React, REST, einfach mal so
Worte eingefügt,
Docker, wie auch immer,
SQL, AWS, also Amazon
und Terraform. Ja.
Für Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Klingt doch eigentlich alles ganz sinnig.
CDK, Terraform.
CDK
ist Terraform.
War CDK nicht diese
Geschichte mit,
nicht, dass ich gerade durcheinander bringe,
ähm, war CDK
nicht die, diese
Geschichte von HashiCorp, also
quasi auch die Terraform
Entwickler, beziehungsweise Terraform-Hersteller,
dass du
quasi
wie kann man das sagen,
deine Terraform-Config
templaten kannst, im Endeffekt.
Du
kannst quasi in
normalen Programmiersprachen,
war das nicht,
bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Nee, CDK vor Terraform,
das meine ich doch.
Das meine ich doch, genau.
Genau, man kann normale
Programmiersprachen
benutzen, quasi
um seine Terraform zu templaten.
Es ist
dann nicht wirklich Terraform,
wie heißt das, HCL
oder so, was da rauskommt,
aber es benutzt im Prinzip den gleichen Kram.
Aber nachdem es quasi nur
Templating ist,
bedeutet das auch, und das ist das, was mich an
CDK ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat,
du kannst da keine Runtime-Logik
in CDK machen.
Also du kannst jetzt beispielsweise nicht
sagen, ey,
ich lasse meine Servernamen
für die VM,
dynamisch während der
Ausführzeit von meinem
Infrastructure as Code generieren
von, sagen wir mal, irgendeinem
zentralen Asset-Management oder so.
Das geht nicht, das ist quasi nur so zur
zur Build-Time.
Du kannst quasi
dann Terraform templaten und am Ende
fällt halt was, ein fertiges Bundle
raus, was du dann ausführen kannst
gegen irgendeinen Cloud-Anbieter und
dann wird deine Infrastruktur aufgebaut.
Zum Zeitpunkt
des Appliance auf deine Infrastruktur
läuft da nichts Dynamisches mehr in
Python oder JavaScript.
Das ist das, was ich ein bisschen doof fand an
CDK. Wundert mich, dass das
sowas noch keiner gebaut hat, auch
mit Pulumi ist das schwierig.
Okay, was sage ich dazu?
Ich glaube, das könnte ganz
nice sein, gerade für Leute, die auf das hier
stehen, steht halt nichts dazu da, was
Gehalt und so
angeht, zumindest sehe ich das jetzt hier nicht.
Also, dass du ein bisschen
betriebliche Altersvorsorge
kriegst, wo die
30 Euro, das ist jetzt
aber nicht gerade viel.
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Klingt jetzt nicht schlecht.
Kann ja schlecht einschätzen.
Klingt stimmig.
Ausflippen
tue ich jetzt nicht.
Ah, ich habe mich doch gerade gewundert, was das aber ist.
Nein, es geht jetzt
gar nichts an.
Das hatten wir ja vorhin.
So, haben wir noch die hier.
Zeige ich mal her.
Systemadministrator
MWX.
Mache einen Unterschied in unserem dynamischen Team.
Miru, danke schön für den Sub und sorry Leute, ich glaube ich habe
gab heute nicht viele, aber ich glaube
ich habe welche übersehen.
Treudel, danke schön für den Sub.
Gar nicht gecheckt.
Darkseid auch wieder am Start.
Ja, verkackt.
Nicht gesehen.
Okay, die haben schon mal ganz
nice Farbverläufe hier unten.
Das Allerwichtigste in so einer
Stellenanzeige.
Radiance
Discover to
Manage.
Alles klar.
Deine Aufgaben. Sie was suchen?
Systemadministrator MWX.
Deine Aufgaben bei RayNet. Installation, Konfiguration,
Wartung von Hardware und Softwarekomponenten.
Ah ja.
Eine
AfD-Stellenausschreibung als PDF.
Immerhin, das muss man
niederlassen, immerhin als PDF.
Und nicht als Doc oder sowas.
Es ist ein Wordpress.
Ja, ganz viele verwenden Wordpress.
Wundert mich nicht.
Da musst du nicht viel Ahnung haben für Wordpress.
Administration
von Windows und Linux Systemen.
Das finde ich schon mal immer
eine fragwürdige Entscheidung.
Weil ernsthaft,
ich kenne kaum einen richtig guten
Linux Admin, der Bock hat, Windows Systeme
zu administrieren. Und umgedreht
ist es witzigerweise auch oft so,
dass so die ganzen Hardcore Windows
Leute,
wenig Bock auf Linux haben.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, es kommt öfters
vor als umgedreht.
Also ich sehe öfters Windows Leute, die sich
auch für Linux interessieren.
Wahrscheinlich, weil Windows so scheiße ist.
Windows Server.
Allerdings sehe ich sehr wenige
Linux Leute, die da gut sind
und zufrieden damit sind,
die sich gleichzeitig auch für Windows Server
interessieren. Ich bin glaube ich
das beste Beispiel für, ich lasse ja keine
Gelegenheit aus, gegen Windows Server zu flamen.
Ich würde im Leben
nichts mit Windows Server machen.
Also ich, Linux only,
kein Windows Server. Ich kenne aber einige
Windows Admins bei uns auch gerade auf der Arbeit,
die selbst sich
ein bisschen mit Linux Systemen beschäftigen.
Aber beides in einem
gibt es nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, gibt es nicht. Wenn du gescheite Leute
haben willst, gibt es nicht.
Ah ja, das ist auch sehr allgemein geschrieben.
Die Tools wären da mal ganz interessant.
Verwaltung von Nutzerkonten und
Zugriffsrechten. Ja, Windows
AD geschiss halt. Managen von aktuellen
Microsoft. Windows Azure
Exchange Teams. Alter.
Äh.
Ausbau, Wartung, Optimierung der LAN und
WLAN Netzwerke über alle Standorte
hinweg. Oh, das wird
so eine eierlegende Wollmilchsau Anzeige
glaube ich langsam, oder?
Installation, Konfiguration,
Hardware, Softwarekomponenten.
Monitoring.
Benchmarkgedöns.
Linux.
Azure Exchange, Sharepoint.
Benutzerrechte.
Netzwerk.
Gewährleistung einer sicheren, effizienten
Vernetzung aller Standorte. Okay.
Patchmanagement.
Netzwerkmonitoring.
Konfiguration, Überwachung
und Datensicherung. Backup.
Storage eventuell auch noch mit dran.
First und Second Level
Support.
Da muss ich tatsächlich schon mal den anderen rausholen.
Schwachstellen. Achso, achja, das auch noch.
Achso, achja, das auch noch.
Penetration Testing.
Sicherheitsupdate.
First and Second Level Support.
Mitarbeiter in Übernahme
von internen und kundenspezifischen Projekten.
Alles klar. Anforderungsanalyse.
Planung, Konfiguration, neue Systeme
zu optimieren. Dokumentation.
Also, seriously, was ist denn das schon wieder?
Wir hatten das geschrieben, Mann.
Die Ein-Mann-IT-Abteilung ist wieder unterwegs.
Suchen die vielleicht fünf verschiedene Leute?
Was du mitbringen solltest?
Zweierberufserfahrung.
Kenntnisse.
IT-Infrastruktur.
Komponenten. Server.
Switches. Firewalls.
Pondierte Kenntnisse im Bereich Microsoft.
Nope.
Pondierte Kenntnisse in Windows-Clients.
Nope. Kenntnisse. Ja.
Kenntnisse im Bereich
IP, Routing,
Proxy, DNS, DHCP.
Ok.
Da hat irgendjemand
mal schnell
gegoogelt
oder Chat-GPT gefragt.
Ach, Moment, Moment.
Vmware, Proxmox, HP,
sowie Storage System. Ach, das auch noch.
Das auch noch. Ja, logisch.
Ja, logisch.
Container, Kubernetes.
Ja, klar. Na klar.
Hat ja noch gefehlt.
Machst du noch Kubernetes-Administration nebenbei?
Erfahrung über Barracuda Firewalls.
Kenn ich nicht.
VPN.
Umfeld.
Kenntnisse in PowerShell.
Anderen Skript schon ausgewiesen.
Soziale Kompetenz.
Also, wenn die irgendjemanden finden, der das alles kann,
dann ist der alles bloß nicht sozial kompetent.
Offener, professioneller und stets lösungsorientierter
Kommunikationsstil.
Viel Platz für eigenverantwortliches Handeln.
Okay, heißt so viel wie, wir haben keinen Plan,
wir machen einfach mal, aber du kriegst den Anschiss,
wenn's nicht geht.
Meine Interpretation des Ganzen.
Flache Hierarchien, direkte Ansprechpartner.
Ja, direkte Ansprechpartner, die dann mit den Schultern zucken.
Vielleicht tu ich ihnen jetzt aber auch unrecht,
aber die Stellenanzeige ist nicht gut.
Team-Events und Work-Life-Balance.
Moment, Team-Events gehen gerade gegen Work-Life-Balance.
Junges, dynamisches Team in einem modernen Büro.
Inivello, Weiterbildungswahl, Einsprache, Wachstum.
Haus, eigenes Fitnessstudio mit Sauna.
Okay.
Quasi eine Abstellkammer mit einem Gewicht drinnen.
Und die Sauna, da drinnen wird's einfach heiß,
weil es kein Fenster hat.
85 Meter große Dachterrasse, Panoramablick.
Ladesäulen für, das finde ich cool.
Vergünstigungen, Rabatte über Bitkom.
So, das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Das haben sau viele.
Kaffee, Tee und Wasser, Flatrate.
Okay, nice.
Okay, ich kann nichts über
Reynet selbst sagen.
Es kann durchaus sein,
dass das hier eine super nice Stelle ist,
aber wie ich hier so oft in diesem Video sage,
wir müssen die Unternehmen, wenn man sie nicht kennt,
danach beurteilen, was die Stellenanzeige für einen Eindruck macht.
Genauso wie das umgedreht ist,
wenn man sich dort bewirbt,
der erste Eindruck zählt
und die Stellenanzeige ist schlecht.
Viel reinschreiben.
Gleiche gute Stellenanzeige.
Ich finde die...
Chatge, würdet ihr euch drauf bewerben,
wenn ihr aus, sagen wir mal, ihr kommt aus Paderborn?
Hättet ihr Bock drauf?
Was sind deine Verbesserungsvorschläge?
Ist mein Arbeitgeber...
Okay, also.
Erstmal würde ich eingrenzen, was man eigentlich sucht.
Also, wenn ihr wirklich jemanden sucht,
der das hier alles kann,
das ist aussichtslos.
Ihr findet niemand, der
Virtualisierung, Storage, Netzwerk,
Kubernetes,
Cloud, Microsoft,
Windows-Zeug, Active Directory
und Linux kann.
Das könnt ihr vergessen.
Das gibt's nicht.
Zumindest nicht, wenn er sich
damit auch ordentlich auskennen soll.
Das gibt's einfach nicht.
Und, und, also.
Als erstes würde ich mir ernsthaft überlegen,
muss der First- und Second-Level-Support machen?
Weil so ziemlich alle wirklich fähigen
Leute, die das...
mega abgeschreckt von First-Level-Support.
Und wenn es nicht wirklich klassischer
First-Level-Support ist, das ist tatsächlich
echt ein Tipp, den können wir vielleicht...
Kannst du vielleicht was damit anfangen?
Wenn es nicht klassischer First-Level-Support
ist,
dann schreib das auch anders rein.
Weil wenn ich First-Level-Support
lese, dann bin ich
instant abgeschreckt.
First-Level-Support für mich heißt,
mich ruft...
keine Ahnung,
die Leute aus der Personalabteilung an
und sagt,
auf meinem Monitor sind so komische
Dinger drauf, was mach ich denn jetzt?
Was kam
beim Wahl-O-Mat raus?
Alter, beim Wahl-O-Mat kam raus,
ich soll irgendwelche
Verschwörungstheorie
5G-Leute,
5G
Skeptiker wählen.
Übernehmen eh die Azubis.
Da muss ich jetzt aber auch mal dazu sagen.
Nur im First-Level-Support sitzen ist jetzt auch
keine gute Ausbildung und schreckt eher ab.
Also wenn ihr eure Azubis behalten
wollt, vielleicht
nicht unbedingt immer in First-Level-Support
stecken, sonst hauen die euch ab.
Niemand macht geile First-Level-Support.
Wobei kann man nicht sagen, es gibt tatsächlich Leute,
die machen das gerne.
Aber ansonsten,
ganz ehrlich, wenn ihr wirklich ernsthaft
jemanden sucht, der das alles kann,
das könnt ihr vergessen.
Das
muss präziser sein
und besser auf das passen.
Wenn ihr jemanden sucht, der Linux hat,
dann fokussiert euch auf den Linux-Bereich
und baut das hier. Da könnt ihr dann durchaus
auch so Sachen hier wie Netzwerk und
ähm
kombiniertes Docker mit ruhig reinnehmen,
weil das eher was ist im Linux-Schwerpunkt.
Wenn ihr jemanden eher sucht, der sich mit
Microsoft-Technologien auskennt,
dann lasst
das Linux-Zeug raus.
Also, das muss
ein bisschen, aus meiner Sicht zumindest,
das muss ein bisschen
runtergebrochen werden eigentlich.
Und letztendlich ist das
ja auch nicht eine Person, muss man auch ehrlich sagen.
Also, wenn ihr das wirklich
alles braucht, braucht ihr, würde ich mal sagen,
mindestens zwei.
Ihr braucht einen, der richtig gut ist, was Microsoft-Sachen
angeht, ihr braucht einen, der richtig gut ist, was
Linux-Sachen angeht und eventuell,
je nachdem, wie sehr es
bei euch ausgebaut ist, natürlich noch jemand,
der sich mit Storage
und Virtualisierung auskennt.
Das sind alles drei
Schwerpunkte, mit denen du komplett
eine Position füllen kannst.
Je nachdem, wieviel es gibt und wie
tiefgreifend denn wirklich erforderlich ist.
Schwierig, also
ich würde mich nicht darauf bewerben, was anderes kann ich
nicht sagen. Und ich muss
nochmal betonen, das sagt nichts
darüber aus, ob das ein guter oder
schlechter Arbeitgeber ist.
Sondern einfach nur meine Ersteinung von der Stellenanzeige
und ich finde ihn nicht gut.
Ja, mehr fällt mir da jetzt nicht zu ein,
was ich noch sagen könnte
an Tipps.
Ja, ich glaube das mit dem First Level ist schon mal
ein guter
Step, wenn man das so nicht reinschreibt.
Ach ja,
aber, aber, wenn
ihr das jetzt nur rausnehmt,
damit sich
dann einer drauf bewirbt
und ihr setzt ihn dann trotzdem in
First Level Support, dann ist er innerhalb von
der Probezeit wieder weg. Das kann ich
jetzt schon sagen. Also nicht nur
rausnehmen, der sollte das dann auch nicht
machen müssen.
Nicht T-Baden, nicht T-Baden.
Ja, gibt es.
Wenn interne
Infrastruktur nicht der Fokus ist,
sollte man vielleicht ein paar Anforderungen komplett
rausnehmen.
Wenn das einfach nur da ist
und keinen juckt, dann sucht man auch
niemanden explizit dafür.
Vielleicht sollte man, also
insgesamt ist das Aufgabenfeld
viel zu groß. Das ist ja wirklich alles.
Ja.
Wenn einer zwei Jahre Erfahrung
hat, erkennt er sich vielleicht ganz brauchbar mit
Linux aus, aber nicht mit dem ganzen Zeug.
Zumal auch, das ist halt das Ding,
das Interesse
der Leute oftmals da
komplett entgegengesetzt läuft.
Ja, jemand der sich super für
sagen wir jetzt mal hier Windows
Microsoft Zeug interessiert,
der hat meistens nicht viel Plan
von Linux, Kubernetes.
Deswegen ist es auch schwierig jemanden zu finden, weil
irgendwo muss sich das so mit den persönlichen
Interessen ja decken.
Ich würde tatsächlich lieber, und wenn ihr einfach
nur jemanden sucht, ihr könnt auch
zwei, drei
Stellenanzeigen machen.
Da bewirbt sich dann vielleicht jemand drauf,
der richtig Plan in Linux hat und ihr stellt fest, ey
der passt richtig gut bei uns hin.
Passt.
Fällt dann der ganze Windows-Krampel weg.
Okay, aber
da findet man wenigstens welche.
Okay, der TÜV.
Moment, wir müssen noch den Entry,
das interessiert mich jetzt, was das hier ist.
Guck mal, die haben, das widerspricht sich.
ja schon im Titel, guck mal.
Die haben hier, die suchen ein Entry
Level Expert.
Falls, falls das
hier die Skills-Stufe
ist, ja. Vielleicht ist es auch
ein Entry Level
IT-Architekt, der für
Expert Labs aber, was auch immer Expert Labs
ist, also, das ist aber unglücklich geschrieben,
weil man kann da, und das ist
auch meine erste Intention gewesen,
was ich da reininterpretiert habe, zu sagen,
wir suchen ein Entry Level
IT-Architekt Expert,
was auch immer Labs dann bedeutet,
aber Entry Level und
Expert ist immer so ein Ding, das klingt irgendwie
ein bisschen komisch zusammen. Okay, sind
bei IBM am Start.
Let's Create ist eine Vision,
die du verbindest mit
Spaß an Teamwork und moderner Technologie.
Das ist so ein typisches,
das ist so ein typischer Intro-Satz,
der rauskommt,
wenn die Marketing-Abteilung
und die Personalabteilung anfängt
Stellenanzeigen zusammenzuschreiben.
Ach, Expert Labs ist quasi
die Abteilung. Ah, ja, also sie suchen
einen Entry Level IT-Architekt.
Okay. Und die Kollegen
in IBM Expert Labs, hier sieht man's,
ja, okay, tun exakt das.
Your Role and
Responsibilities.
Kundenprobleme zu identifizieren, zu
durchdringen,
Hyper-Gadget, und zu lösen
ist für dich eine spannende Herausforderung.
Moderne IT-Unternehmen
und die
innovativsten Werkzeuge
begeistern dich.
Kommt drauf an,
was sie darunter verstehen.
50 Bewerbungen sind schon ordentlich
viel, ja. Zumal wir heute
in einer Zeit leben, wo
vieles, wo das sehr gefragt
ist. Also, du hast
zwei kleine, also
ein, mindestens ein kleines Problem,
und zwar, viele
suchen nicht unbedingt
händeringend Juniorstellen
sondern Leute, die ein bisschen Erfahrung
haben. Da kannst du
jetzt nichts für,
aber das ist so. Das heißt,
gerade bei ein bisschen Advanced- und
Senior-Jobs, da herrscht extremer
Mangel.
Was nicht heißt,
dass es keine Stellen für Junior-
Leute gibt. Aber
vom Angebot-Nachfrage-Dings würde ich
sagen, es fehlen eher die bisschen Advanced- und
Senior-Leute mehr.
Auf der anderen Seite kann ich zu deiner Bewerbung natürlich
nichts sagen, keine Ahnung. Ich bin auch kein Personaler, also ich bin
auch niemand, der das jetzt irgendwie gut
aus Personalsicht einschätzen könnte. Ich kann
am höchsten sagen, mir gefällt es. Das heißt auch lange
nicht, dass der Personalabteilung gefällt, wenn mir das
gefällt. Eine Sache, die
tatsächlich immer gut ankommt,
ist, ja,
Github-Projekte, beziehungsweise falls
du irgendwelche
Sachen online
hast, die man sich angucken kann,
ist das sicherlich auch nice.
Wer weiß, was du da schon gebaut hast.
Das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt. Also,
Github ist sehr beliebt bei
Entwicklerstellen.
Geht sogar so weit, dass bestimmt
der ein oder andere heutzutage
sagt, wenn sich ein Entwickler bewirbt ohne
Github-Link, guck ich es mir gar nicht an.
Gibt es bestimmt welche.
Also Github-Profil sollte
auf jeden Fall rein.
Ansonsten, ich kann dir leider auch
keinen, ja, ich würde dir gerne
irgendwie einen ultimativen Tipp geben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also eine Sache, die sicherlich hilft,
ist, ich weiß nicht, wie du dich bewirbst,
ob es mehr oder weniger
online mit
Uploaden
sie jetzt hier ihre Bewerbung ist.
Auch wenn das viele Unternehmen
anbieten, ich
glaube,
das muss ich so sagen, weil ich selbst nicht ausprobiert
habe in letzter Zeit,
ich glaube,
dass es nicht verkehrt ist,
anstelle sich
bei 50
random Unternehmen
nur mit Lebenslauf zu
bewerben, gerade wenn der Lebenslauf sehr nur nach
15 ist.
Es ist vielleicht besser,
sich 5 rauszusuchen
und ein individuelles
Intro, also irgendein individuelles
Anschreiben noch mitzuschicken.
Wenn du dir dann 5 Stück
raussuchst, auf die du Bock hast,
dich ein bisschen schlau machst über die
und dann ein gut geschriebenes Anschreiben
noch mitschickst, gerade wenn du jetzt nicht den
den super herausstechendsten
Lebenslauf hast, kannst du somit bestimmt
persönlich Punkte sammeln.
Ansonsten, ich kann dir keine
großartigen Tipps geben.
Daten, Algorithmen
und Automatisierung sind für dich keine
Mysterien, sondern wertvolle...
Wer hat diesen Satz wieder
geschrieben, IBM? Keck, wait!
Das ist ein...
Das ist ja so ein bescheuerter
Satz!
Ist das ein Chat...
Ist das eine Chat-GPT-Stellenanzeige oder was?
Das ist so...
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Chat-GPT-Anzeige
ist. Ich glaube, das ist was rauskommt, wenn
Marketing und Personalabteilung
eine Technikstelle ausschreiben und keine Ahnung
haben, um was es da geht. Whatever.
Dann packe
diese Themen... Dann packe diese
Themen... Was? Dann packe
diese Thema mit uns an
und starte deine Karriere bei einem
weltweiten Technologie-Champion!
IBM hat jetzt nicht unbedingt
den Ruf
so super krass zu sein noch.
Nicht, dass sie
vereinzelt auch coole Sachen rausgebracht
haben, aber weiß nicht, ob
IBM noch so die
Technik hat.
Das Ding ist,
was die Leute damit verbunden haben,
früher glaube ich nicht.
Eine familiäre Atmosphäre.
Alter, das ist IBM, das ist eines der
größten Technik-Läden überhaupt. Die haben
keine familiäre Atmosphäre.
Das ist Business Enterprise Stonkshit
extrem. Wette ich mit euch.
Das ist so...
Oldschool-Business-Kram
Enterprise, IBM.
Da ist sicherlich nichts mit familiärer
Atmosphäre.
Und inklusive...
Das ergibt überhaupt...
Was ist das für ein Satz, Mann?
So, das ist die letzte Stellenanzeige,
die wir uns heute angucken. Also, die zwei,
die wir noch haben und die ich gerade aufgemacht habe,
weil sonst komme ich nicht hinterher.
Was ist das für ein Satz?
Eine familiäre Atmosphäre
und inklusive
Kultur?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur aus
dem Englischen übersetzt.
Sodass sie eben very inclusive
und sowas sind. Das ist einfach nur
wir übersetzt, was so in Deutsch
keiner, keiner in Deutsch würde schreiben.
Jeder ist willkommen oder irgendwie
sowas, aber...
Inklusive
aber das wird man so normalerweise
mit einem Growth-Mindset
sowie Freiraum für deine eigenen
Kreativitäten. Nur es läuft ein gezieltes
Onboarding-Programm, dieser besteht aus verschiedenen Komponenten
nationalen, also remote,
on-site, beziehungsweise hybrid. Okay, da geht's
richtig ab.
Übrigens, ich sag's ja, ich hab's ja öfter
schon gesagt, ich find's jedes Mal merkwürdig.
Wenn eine der Vorteile
ist, sie werden richtig eingearbeitet.
Ich bin der Meinung, eine ordentliche
Einarbeitung sollte so im
ureigenen Interesse des
Arbeitgebers liegen, dass du für dein
Geld, was er dir ja auch vom ersten
Tag an bezahlen muss, auch was machen
kannst. Wenn die dich nicht
richtig einarbeiten,
dann sind die selber dran schuld, dass sie Geld
zum Fenster rausschmeißen. Ja, ich weiß,
es gibt genug Läden, wo das nicht passiert,
wo du hingesetzt wirst und es wird gesagt,
ey, mach halt einfach mal. Aber die
sind dumm.
Die sind richtig, die sind absolut pipige.
Ich finde, das hier sollte eigentlich jeder, der
irgendwie normal tickt im Kopf,
machen seine Leute ordentlich einarbeiten.
So eine aufmaßend technische, fachliche
Ausbildung kombiniert mit direkten
Hands-On-Tätigkeit bei unseren Kunden.
What? Was sucht ihr nochmal?
Moment.
Bist du dann jemand,
der zu Leuten hinfährt und ihr Storage-System
updatet oder so? Bist du
dann so jemand, wie der eine, der
bei uns den USB-Stick, den USB-
Stick in den Fahrstuhlschacht geschmissen hat
von IBM? So
einen Vor-Ort-Service-Typ oder wie?
Liest sich ein bisschen so.
Bei uns, bei uns
auf der alten Arbeit, bei meiner alten Arbeit war mal
ein IBM-Service-Typ da.
Der hatte auch eine Hands-On-Tätigkeit bei
uns durchzuführen. Der hatte nämlich
einen USB-Stick dabei und sollte
damit unser Storage-System updaten.
Und
dem ist der USB-Stick aus der Hand gefallen
beim Aussteigen aus dem Fahrstuhl.
Und da ist der USB-Stick
genau in die Lücke gefallen zwischen
Stockwerk und Fahrstuhl.
So diese kleine Lücke, die entsteht bei einem
Fahrstuhl, wenn die Tür aufgeht. So unten da,
wo die Tür ist. So dieser Zentimeter.
Ist der USB-Stick
reingefallen, den Fahrstuhlschacht
runter
und damit nicht genug
unten in die Öl-Pfanne.
Das konnten dann erst
nächsten Montag oder so der Hausmeister
rausholen.
Aber eins muss man den Leuten bei IBM
sagen. Die waren tatsächlich da sehr
erfinderisch.
Die haben dann in Israel angerufen.
Also
viele Storage-Systeme von IBM.
Die hat IBM ja auch nur eingekauft.
Und anscheinend
saßen da einige Entwickler in Israel.
Die haben in Israel angerufen und
da war glaube ich irgendwie Feiertag
oder so oder Wochenende. Frag mich nicht.
Oder schon Wochenende wegen
dem Zeitunterschied irgendwie so. Und da ist
dann noch einer dort in Israel zurück auf
die Arbeit gefahren und hat
ihm dann irgendwie per securem
E-Mail-Anhang auf sein
Laptop die für uns gepatchte
Firmware geschickt, dass er die sich
da, super advanced das Zeug ist, haben sie
hingekriegt. Und wir waren da nur dabei
zum damaligen, ich hab da ein Video übrigens
drüber gemacht, wer sich das genau angucken will
hier.
Das hier.
Also wer es ausführlich wissen
will, kann sich das hier angucken.
Wir haben da nur dabei
gesessen und mussten
zugucken.
Ja, der USB-Stick hätte ein Agile Ending
gebraucht. Dein Aufgang.
Was? Bring your full
self to work.
Ihr wisst nicht,
was ihr schreibt, Leute.
Denn wir wollen dich so wie du bist.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, Leute.
Das wollt ihr nicht.
Ich weiß das genau, dass ihr das nicht wollt.
Ihr glaubt vielleicht,
dass ihr das wollt.
Ihr wollt das aber
definitiv nicht.
Das ist so,
wie wenn Leute
sagen so, ja, fühl dich ganz
wie zu Hause. Das ist so ein Spruch, der gerne bei irgendwelchen
Filmen und so kommt. Fühlt euch
ganz wie zu Hause und dann würdest
du dich aufs Sofa setzen und erstmal die Hose
ausziehen.
Der meint das auch nicht wortwörtlich.
Du entwickelst
ein tiefgreifendes Verständnis...
Alter, das hört ja gar nicht mal auf, dieses IBM
Ding hier. Das will ich mir nicht alles durchlesen.
Also, keine Ahnung.
IBM.
Komisch übersetzte Stellenanzeige.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht übel.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck,
wahrscheinlich gar nicht übel.
Ich habe nichts von
Home Office oder Remote gelesen.
Home on Weekends?
Wait a minute.
Selbstverständlich bin ich
Home on Weekends.
Wo denn sonst?
Das gibt's nicht.
Da hätte ich schon mal
keinen Bock drauf. Wenn
Travel auch Weekends und
so mit einbezieht, es sei denn, ihr bezahlt
super krass.
Wie kann man denn eine Ausbildung machen, die nicht staatlich
anerkannt ist? Da hast du doch keine Ausbildung gemacht.
Da hast du ja irgendein Code Camp besucht oder so.
Okay, ja, das ist irgendwie sowas.
Wie lange geht denn das? Zwei Wochen oder so?
Einen Monat?
Nee. Ja, dann wundert's
mich nicht, dass
das Interesse sich in Grenzen hält.
Da gucken in Deutschland
immer noch viele drauf, dass du eine
abgeschlossene Ausbildung
hast als Physi oder Fachinformatik
Anwendungsentwicklung.
Also sag mal so, wenn du gerade
Junior-Quereinsteiger ohne
groß was vorzuzeigen ist, glaube
ich, nicht einfach.
In Stellenanzeigen wird auch viel
gelabert, wenn der Tag lange ist.
Also du hast mit einer Ausbildung auf jeden Fall
deutlich bessere Chancen, als
wenn man nur einen Code Camp besucht hat.
Und jetzt,
ist tatsächlich eine ziemlich gute
Gelegenheit noch, für dieses Jahr
sich einen Ausbildungsplatz zu suchen.
Die fangen 1.8., 1.9.
an.
Die sind jetzt viele am gucken noch.
Also du hast, gerade mit sowas,
das ist eine super Sache für eine
Bewerbung, als
macht sich bestimmt super in einer
Bewerbung als Fachinformatiker
Anwendungsentwicklung.
An String erinnern, ja, habe ich gerade.
Also,
da hast du denke ich,
gute Chance eine Ausbildungsstelle zu
finden.
DevOps Engineer Kubernetes.
Ups.
Smart Clip.
EdTech Entwicklungseinheit
der RTL.
Aha.
Die Shopping Queen. Ne, das war ProSieben,
glaube ich. Ich musste das mal gucken.
Das war der schlimmsten
Fernsehsendung ever.
Die Shopping Queen, Mann.
So ein Schrott. Okay, wenigstens muss ich
dafür keine Gebühren bezahlen.
Unsere proprietäre
Werbetechnik ist auf spezielle Bedürfnisse
von Europäern.
Okay, bla bla bla, das müssen wir nicht lesen.
Smart TV Clip.
Okay.
Ich finde, das sieht aus wie
eine Webseite, die sagt,
ich möchte ein bisschen so aussehen wie Apple,
ohne Apple zu sein.
Findet ihr nicht auch? Das hat ein bisschen was davon.
Ja, natürlich immer super,
super glückliche Leute. Ja, so gucke ich auch
immer, wenn ich mir Werbung angucken muss.
Aber, muss sagen, es ist eine
cleane, cleane Webseite.
Ist gut gemacht.
Auch wenn ich ja persönlich
dieses, dieses
geänderte Scrollverhalten im Desktop
echt nicht abkann.
Auf Twitter sind die auch. Okay, guck mal.
Sind wohl
doch nicht auf Twitter.
Sind sie denn auf LinkedIn am Start?
Auf LinkedIn sind sie da, okay.
Okay, DevOps Engineer.
Bist du Teil unseres System Operation Teams?
Du bist verantwortlich für die
weitere Automatisierung und Betrieb unserer Infrastruktur.
Ja gut, passt ja eigentlich
ganz gut.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die meisten
DevOps Engineers ehemalige
Server Admins sind,
ist das thematisch auch irgendwie ganz passend.
Dabei arbeitest du im engen
Austausch mit den Entwicklungsteams.
Dich erwartet bei uns hervorragende
technische Kollegen,
von denen du lernen kannst. Wir fokussieren uns auf
Automatisierung und halten mehr von
Moment, was?
Wir fokussieren uns auf Automatisierung und halten
mehr von Latest
als von LTS.
Das ist eine
gewagte Aussage,
die ich ganz cool finde,
die vielleicht im Business
Enterprise Umfeld ein bisschen fragwürdig ist.
Was aber auch heißt,
Latest, Leute, Arch by the way.
Arch Linux direkt
auf den Server drauf. Bäm.
Scheiß drauf.
Das muss Schmerzen verursachen.
Und wir stehen total auf
Open Source.
Deine Position in unserem Team.
Konzipiere und automatisiere
Entwicklerplattformen für schnelles,
funktionales Feedback, hohe qualitative
Ergebnisse und maximale...
Leute, ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was die von mir
wollen. Versteht ihr das, was die
von mir wollen? Oder
von uns wollen?
Konzipiere und automatisiere
Entwicklerplattformen...
No-Code-No-Code-Geschiss, oder was?
Für schnelles,
funktionales Feedback, hohe
qualitative Ergebnisse, maximale...
Was wollt ihr mir mit dem Satz überhaupt
sagen? Also unter der
Entwicklerplattform verstehe ich, unter
anderem, gibt es verschiedene Definitionen davon,
oder im Kontext von dieser
Anzeige könnte ich mir unter einer Entwicklerplattform
sowas vorstellen, wie
man hat einen Kubernetes Cluster
und auf dem testen die
Entwickler ihre Software. Allerdings sollen
sie das möglichst eigenständig machen können.
Das heißt, du baust irgendwelche Deployment
Pipelines, irgendwelche Dinger, dass die relativ schnell
sehen, ob Tests klappen, Tests
fehlschlagen, irgendeine neue Testumgebung
anlegen über irgendeinen Bot oder sowas,
dass sie schnell deployen können,
gucken, wie ihre neuen Sachen aussehen, sowas stelle
ich mir unter Entwicklerplattformen fest.
Ansonsten
ist der Satz echt...
Keine Ahnung...
Das kann alles sein und nichts...
Ja, das ist ja
sowas, was ich gerade versucht habe zu beschreiben.
Also quasi eine Internal Developer
Plattform.
Binde moderne Tools an
DevOps Pipelines unter der
Beachtung der funktionalen Sicherheit an.
Also wisst ihr was ich witzig
finde? Das hier ist so übelst
lässig und cool
und nice geschrieben und hier unten ist krasser
Business Talk angesagt. So als hätten
das und das zwei komplett
unterschiedliche Leute geschrieben.
Binde moderne Tools an DevOps
Pipelines unter Beachtung der funktionalen
Sicherheit an. Begleite unsere Teams
auf unserer DevOps Journey.
Leute, meint ihr
die sind agil
wake-upped?
Oder brauchen die noch einen
agilen Wake-up-Call
und das passende Landing
für ihre Use Cases?
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Begleite unsere
Stärke und Softwareentwicklung.
Trage unmittelbar zur Verbesserung einer
hochmodellen Infrastruktur auf der Grundlage von
Kubernetes und Cloud Hyperscaling.
Endlich! Da habe ich heute
den ganzen Tag drauf gewartet.
Dass einer mit Hyperscaler um die Ecke
kommt.
Ja, ich erzähle es euch monatelang
jetzt schon. Cloud-Anbieter sind out,
Hyperscaler sind in, obwohl es genau das gleiche ist.
Endlich! RTL. Wo muss
erst RTL kommen?
Schütze und sichere unsere Systemumgebung.
Sowas wie Backstage. Ja, kann sein.
Ja.
Vermutlich sowas.
Mindestens fünf Jahre Berufserfahrung.
Da könntet ihr ja mal zumindest,
also fünf Jahre könnten wir vielleicht schon eine
Seniorstelle draus machen.
Wenn man auf solche Sachen steht, ja.
Letztendlich ist wichtig, was gemacht wird, was bezahlt wird.
Ob das Senior oder Forscher, ist ja jetzt vollkommen wurscht.
DevOps,
Engineering, Infrastruktur, Code, Docker und Kubernetes
in Linux. Cloud-Kenntnisse.
Idealerweise AWS und
Google Cloud. Alter, könnte ich mich direkt bewerben hier.
Ich kenne mich mit allem aus, was die haben wollen.
Erfahrungen mit Shell-Skripten,
Craylock, Grafana, Prometheus, Python, Jenkins. Ey,
Bam! Let's go!
Ich gehe zur Erde. Nein, ich gehe nicht zur Erde. Ich bleibe da, wo ich bin.
Ownership, Eigeninitiative,
Selbstmanagement, Bereitschaft,
durchstetig
weiterzuentwickeln.
Fokus auf Effizient und Qualität.
Leute, wir wissen alle,
was ist
Quality? Ihr wisst
genauso gut wie ich.
Quality is Destiny, haben wir gelernt
bei
Amazon war das, glaube ich sogar.
Unser Ansatz, wir werden von
spannenden Projekten angetrieben,
die Freiraum für persönliche Gestaltung und Entwicklung
möglich sind. Wir sind stolz darauf,
die neuesten Technologien einzusetzen, um
an der Spitze zu bleiben. Darunter
Node.js, C++. Okay,
wir fangen erstmal mit zwei Technologien an, die
jeweils schon, keine Ahnung,
30 Jahre alt sind
und
15 Jahre
alt sind.
Und dann kommt Jenkins,
Java,
Python, SQL, TypeScript,
JavaScript, React, Docker,
Kubernetes, AWS, Google Cloud und viel mehr.
Okay, einfach mal alles reingeschmissen.
Tools und Ausrüstung, wir versorgen dich
mit self-jahrelichem Equipment, egal ob du Mac,
Linux... Aha!
Sehr gut!
Freie Betriebssysteme, auswahlfrei,
sehr großartig, sehr nice, sehr, sehr
nice, finde ich extrem gut.
Flexible Arbeitsumgebung,
von der Möglichkeit
Remote zu arbeiten, überein auf dem
Honor System Based Ansatz
für die... Ist das sowas wie
Skill Based Matchmaking?
Für Arbeitszeiten?
Ich glaube, die wollen uns damit
sagen, es wird
erstmal den Leuten vertraut, so nach
dem Motto, die haben alle genug Ehre, nicht zu
bescheißen. Ja,
Vertrauensarbeit, sowas, genau, ja.
Unsere neueste Option
für eine 4-Tage-Woche, wissen wir, wie wichtig
die... Kontinuierliche Entwicklung,
die Investitionen, was...
Wir bieten vielfältige... Okay,
was wir darüber hinaus bieten, wir kümmern uns um unsere...
Deshalb bieten wir attraktive Sozialleistungen
wie Zuschüsse in Deutschland.
Ja, kostenloses RTL
plus Premium-Abonnent, ja.
Das habe ich unbedingt gebraucht,
natürlich. Vergünstigungen
durch Corporate Benefits,
erlebnisreiche Firmen-Events
und vieles mehr.
Werde Teil unseres hochmotivierten
Teams. Okay, Chat,
auch wenn ich RTL jetzt nicht unbedingt
ähm, ja, nicht der
größte RTL-Fan bin,
ich muss sagen,
vielleicht auch, weil das mein
Spezialgebiet hier alles ist,
ich muss sagen,
es ist die beste Stellenanzeige heute gewesen.
Was sagt ihr?
Chatge?
Mittel? Okay.
Geschmackssache, für mich war das die beste
heute. Oder bundesweit
im Homeoffice.
Die Tätigkeit ist so nichtssagend.
Naja, ich finde,
man kann sich schon ganz gut ein Bild von
machen.
Wirklich, die konkreten Sachen fehlen
jetzt natürlich.
Aber wenn das hier das ist, was ich
reininterpretiere,
passt das zum Rest.
Du kümmerst dich im Endeffekt drum, dass Software-Entwickler
ihre Arbeit möglichst gut erledigen können.
Also genau das, was eigentlich
ein DevOps-Engineer machen sollte.
Vor zwei Jahren hast du gesagt,
analoges Fernsehen soll sterben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das und wie ich das gesagt
hab, aber ich hätte damit keine
Probleme, weil ich konsumiere eigentlich kein
normales Fernsehen mehr.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass ich nicht für sowas
arbeiten würde, wenn die Bezahlung
stimmt.
Und ich was suchen würde, was ich nicht mache.
Weil,
was juckt's mich,
was mit analogem Fernsehen ist.
Also,
ich finde das nicht schlecht. Für mich war das heute die beste
Stellenanzeige.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns jetzt die letzte Stellenanzeige
an für heute. Und zwar, mal gucken, ob der
TÜV Nord
das heute noch toppen kann.
Die Webseite ist schon mal ganz merkwürdig
formatiert.
Das Logo ist auch
kaputt. Das hier auch kaputt.
Ne.
Ah ja, das ist wahrscheinlich, weil ich's
geblockt hab.
Das TÜV-Logo
ist geblockt. Da gucken wir uns
das hier an. Hier geht's.
Wobei ich bei beidem...
Whatever. Okay, Stellen
TÜV IT
TÜV Informationstechnik,
Anstellung unbefressen, flexible
Absprache.
Wie? Also,
das Intro von dieser Stellenanzeige
ist ja mal
ein Musterbeispiel in,
wie kann ich mit möglichst
uninteressanten Sachen möglichst viel
Platz füllen, oder?
Die erste Seite, komplett voll mit
nicht komplett unwichtigen Sachen, aber
viel zu voll, man.
Was wir dir bieten? Wir bieten dir einen sicheren
Arbeitsplatz, ein tarifgeschütztes Gehalt,
was auch heißt,
nicht so super viel.
Kann gut und schlecht
sein.
Erstmal ist es gut,
wenn es einen Tarifvertrag gibt,
weil das auch oftmals für
außertarifliche Sachen, zwar nicht verpflichtend
ist, aber sich oftmals orientiert dran wird.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, okay, es gab jetzt
für die Tarifverträge
so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 4% Erhöhung,
das kriegen die anderen auch. Ist immer gut,
wenn es sowas gibt. Unsere Homeoffice und
Teilzeitangebote unterstützen
dich dabei, deine Berufs...
Gut, dass ihr es schreibt, würde mich natürlich
interessieren, ob das nicht nur gesagt ist,
um es zu sagen, oder auch wirklich dann so
gelebt wird, wie man schon sagt.
Du arbeitest in der, okay, bla,
bla, bla, unsere
ÖPNV-Anmeldung.
Wir fördern unsere Beschäftigungs...
...
Okay.
Was du bei uns bewegst, du entwickelst
IT-Security-Standards der Zukunft
und bist zuständig für die Erstellung, Bewertung
und Präsentation von Spezifikationen
für IT-Systeme und Komponenten der Zukunft.
Klingt
jetzt irgendwie so
langweilig?
Ich meine, man ist ja auch IT-Sicherheitsexpert,
Schwerpunkt, Konformitätsprüfung
und technische Spezifikation.
Das klingt, allein schon der Titel dieser Stelle
oder der Name der Stelle
klingt nach Bürokratie-Overload
as fuck.
Ähm, das klingt
so ein bisschen nach Sesselfurzerstelle.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es anders beschreiben soll.
Dabei unterstützt du
Behörden, Hersteller sowie Betreibungsumfeld
der IT-Sicherheit und Digitalisierung.
Zudem arbeitest du in Einschlägen,
Gremien und Verbe... Boah!
What the fuck, Alter!
Das klingt auf jeden Fall nach nix für mich.
Du verantwortest die Prüfung
und Bewertung von Sale of the Art IT-Produkten
System nach anerkannten Sicherheitskriterien.
Okay.
Ich glaube, auf sowas muss man der richtige Typ
für sein und Bock drauf haben. Dann ist das
super nice, das Beste, was es gibt.
Aber für mich ist das nix.
Tatsächlich, das muss man ihnen lassen, richtig?
Relativ spezifisch, um was es geht.
Das ist ein großer Pluspunkt, ja?
Da habt ihr recht.
Hochschulabschluss?
Zum Teufel, brauchst du dafür einen Master?
Okay, Nickit.
Warum brauchst du dafür jetzt
einen
Hochschulabschluss, um das zu machen?
Es schließt sich mir jetzt noch nicht,
aber wenn sie wollen, dann wollen sie.
Fortgeschrittene Kenntnisse
in der IT-Sicherheit, Erfahrung im Programmieren,
zum Beispiel bei Python, Java,
ja, mit Git und GitLab.
Da programmier ich auch immer.
Und in der Kryptographie.
Man kann sagen,
wer schreibt denn das noch mit ph?
Der TÜV.
Da weißt du, wer die Stellenanzeige
geschrieben hat, Mann.
Idealerweise Erfahrung
im Bereich Requirements Engineering
oder Spezifikation Technik Anforderungen.
Ja, jetzt weiß ich auch, warum du studiert haben musst.
Für XML.
Analytisches
Arbeiten, Teamkreis und
Kommunikationsvermögen, sicheres Englisch
und Schrift- sowie Reisebereitschaft.
Dann
freuen wir uns auf deine aussagekräftige
Bewerbung.
Also
für mich wäre es
nix.
Man scheitert ja allein schon hier daran.
Ich habe keinen Master oder keinen Doktor oder sonst was.
Ne.
Ich hoffe, es ist gut bezahlt.
Man weiß es nicht genau.
Jan-Fried, dein Schiff für den SAP.
Also mich macht es jetzt nicht so
so heiß, die
Stellenanzeige.
Bachelor war mit. Ist egal, habe ich auch nicht.
Tja.
Ich glaube, wenn man auf sowas steht, ist das die geilste
Stelle ever.
Ich stehe nicht auf sowas.
Mehr kann ich dazu jetzt nicht sagen.
So Chat, ich hoffe, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Genug Stellenanzeigen für heute.
Waren wir aber fleißig, müssen wir sagen.
Ich glaube, so viele Stellenanzeigen wie heute
haben wir noch in keinem anderen Stream
durchgekriegt. Das waren bestimmt
keine Ahnung 12, 13
Dinger durch
durchgeprügelt.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch sinnvoll
was gesagt zu jeder.
Die Gehälter beim TÜV sind auch nicht
insane. Na gut.
Wundert mich auch nicht.
Es klang jetzt auch nicht wie an einer Stelle,
die super krass bezahlt wird.
Morgen noch mal ein Stream.
Ganz normal, morgen früh, wie immer.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wann es genau losgeht.
Entweder um 9 oder um 10,
je nachdem, ob ich da vor eine Runde rennen gehe
oder nicht.
Ich habe jetzt die gesamte
letzten, die gesamte, ohne Mist,
ich glaube, ich habe die letzten 14
Tage
nicht einen Tag
mal richtig Pause
gemacht.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht.
Ich glaube letzten Sonntag.
Doch, letzten Sonntag habe ich
mich mal ausgeruht.
Ich bin ansonsten jeden Tag
rennen gewesen oder Fahrrad fahren.
Das ist eine super nice
Abwechslung, weil
wenn dir es im Bein ein bisschen weh tut,
vom Rennen und du den nächsten
Tag nicht rennen gehen willst,
fährst du einfach Fahrrad.
Das belastet ganz
andere Regionen und Tag danach
und irgendwie hilft es auch ein bisschen dazu,
dass sich die Beine wieder dann besser anfühlen
und also an den
Stellen, die man braucht zum Rennen
und am Tag später gehe ich dann wieder rennen.
Warum so lange keine Videos?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Irgendwie hatte ich in letzter Zeit
nicht so
den Zug dazu.
Läuft die Cringe Show schon? Keine Ahnung.
Ich gucke ESC nicht.
Ich weiß weder wer für uns antritt
noch
was da sonst so abgeht.
Juckt mich null.
Es übrigens
Tradekost
scheitert nicht an
keinen Themen für Videos.
Ich habe eine riesig lange Liste
habe ich schon oft genug erwähnt an Themen.
Stehen auch ganz viele Sachen, die ich
euch versprochen habe noch aus.
Zum Beispiel, dass wir uns zusammen mal meine Bewerbung
angucken.
Aber ich hatte nicht so den Zug dazu.
In letzter Zeit.
Hast du Gamescom News gesehen?
Du meinst das mit
der Sicherheitslücke?
Oder was?
Oder was meinst du genau?
Ja, das kenne ich.
Die haben einen auf Modern Solution gemacht.
Ja, genau.
Das kenne ich.
Dass sie den Typ, der gemeldet hat,
dass man Kundendaten abgreifen kann
über ihre Webseite erst mal angezeigt haben.
Weißt du, ich weiß nicht wovon
du sprichst.
Ja, Leute.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Dass so viele so lange
dabei waren.
Ich gehe jetzt auf
Afgklo.
Bisschen MMO Kreiselcrime machen.
Und dann sehen wir uns morgen früh zum
Aufwachstream wieder.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
Und danke für die Subs.
Bis dann.